So, Chat, auf geht's.
Wie viele YouTube-Tabs ich immer offen habe?
Ja, ich habe schon ein paar Videos offen, die man sich gleich angucken kann.
Aber nicht alle, sondern vielleicht ein bisschen viel.
Grifel, zwei Monate, danke schön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription.
Big Brain Subscriptions hier wieder.
Das ist irgendeine Mario, Kirby, Sonic, frag mich nicht.
Ich, äh, Musik-Compilation.
Hier, wir machen das letzte Video.
Da haben sich ein paar Leute beschwert, wie cringe das Intro ist.
Aber ich wusste, dass das Intro, ich sage es ja sogar selbst.
Ich bin nicht eingeloggt, das ist geil, ich kriege das Video empfohlen.
Vielleicht kriegt noch mehr Leute das Video auf ihrer Startseite empfohlen.
11k Views in, äh, klar, in 10 Stunden oder so ist schon okay.
Ich gebe zu, ich gebe zu, das Intro.
Das Intro in dem Video war auch cringe.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht, ey, das ist so, das ist so, so schlecht, dass es schon wieder gut ist.
Das muss ich nicht nochmal aufnehmen.
Und morgen ist es soweit, ne?
We nice.
We nice unleashed.
Mal gucken, ob die Leute spielen.
Ich bin ja mal echt gespannt.
Wer steht und fällt mit, ob es ordentlichen Content gibt.
Ansonsten, schauen wir mal.
Was mich wundert.
Ist, dass irgendwie noch keiner der größeren, der größeren Battlefield-Channels das ganze aufgegriffen hat.
Gibt es mein altes Intro noch?
Du meinst das Tetris-Intro?
Das gibt es noch, ja.
Aber Intros sind out 2020 auf YouTube.
Weil die Leute haben mittlerweile so eine kurze Aufmerksamkeitsspanne,
dass wenn du 8 Sekunden Intro machst am Anfang, die Leute gleich ausschalten.
Das ist kein Witz.
Döner, Dönerbruder.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Ist ja auch nice.
Ich meine, ich kriege nicht mehr so viele Views.
Wie vor dem ganzen Zeug.
Außerdem dauert es immer eine Weile, bis der Algorithmus wieder das Ganze hier aufpickt.
Bis sich die Abos aufgeräumt haben.
Das ist immer ein bisschen demotivierend, wenn man nach einer Weile auf YouTube wieder anfängt.
Weil man kriegt erst mal instant D-Abos bei jedem Video.
Das liegt aber gar nicht mal so sehr daran, dass die Videos irgendwie viel beschissener sind als früher.
Oder anders sind oder sonst wo.
Du kannst exakt die gleichen Videos machen.
Und es kann genauso vielen Leuten gefallen.
YouTube räumt irgendwie Abos auf, sobald man was hochlädt.
Ich verstehe den Sinn davon nicht.
Aber es ist halt YouTube-Logik.
Das muss man nicht verstehen.
Weil das sieht man immer.
Erst mal instant D-Abos und dann über den restlichen Tag über gibt es dann wieder welche.
Ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Aber es ist nicht schlimm.
Es dauert immer ein bisschen, bis man im Algorithmus wieder landet.
Ja.
Und dazu kommt, eins darf man ja auch nicht vergessen.
Ich muss euch mal kurz was bei mir auf dem Channel zeigen.
Ich könnte übrigens was, wisst ihr, was mir gerade auffällt?
Ich könnte mal übelsten Low-Effort-Content machen auf YouTube.
Und einfach Max reagiert auf sein erstes Video.
Wobei ihr wisst ja, das ist gar nicht das erste Video.
Das erste Video gibt es nicht mehr, weil da Musik drinne war.
Aber, wobei die ersten zwei Videos gibt es, glaube ich, nicht mehr, weil da Musik drinne war.
Aber das geht auch.
Das geht auch.
Das ist ein gutes Thema.
Max ärgert sich.
Hacker-Lobby.
Mit massive Soundqualität, Leute.
Ladebildschirm.
Okay, doch.
Das Problem ist, so ein flawless...
So schlecht ist die Audio-Quali doch gar nicht, oder?
Tri4al schüttelt man natürlich nicht so einfach mal aus, aus dem Armgelenk.
Naja doch, die Audio-Quali sackt schon ziemlich.
Live-Reaction im Stream, das ist langweilig.
Ich glaube nicht, was soll ich da großartig zu sagen?
Vielleicht nachher, vielleicht nachher.
Aber das könnte ich echt mal machen.
Reactor auf mein erstes Video.
Hat der Friseur ja auch gemacht.
Hat er, hat er, hat er...
Eif...
Hat er eigentlich mal wieder was Neues gemacht jetzt?
Nee.
Huuuuh.
Oh, was, warum krieg ich denn bitte schon jetzt Battlefield 4 Revolution Events angezeigt?
YouTube hat sich gedacht, oh ja, 7 Jahre nach Release.
Das ist jetzt eine gute Idee, dass ich dir Battlefield 4 Videos zeige.
Excellent.
Oh, der Senior DevOps ist da jetzt.
Das ist gut, jetzt geben wir auch nicht zu viel Geld in der Cloud raus.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das hab ich auch, äh, pre-serif.
Dass ich teilweise Videos gar nicht angezeigt bekomme von Channels, die ich abonniert hab und eine Weile nichts gemacht haben.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Es sackt eigentlich, ne, wenn man überlegt.
Gerade Leute, die wieder am Start sind.
Und, äh, dann interessiert es mich ja vielleicht erst recht.
Naja.
Aber eins darf man auch auf YouTube nicht vergessen, ne.
YouTube ist halt auch übelst Competitive Plattform geworden mittlerweile.
Also, es gibt mittlerweile DEUTLICH...
mehr Content als Leute, die diesen Content überhaupt gucken können.
Und ich rede jetzt nicht von random Content, die irgendwelche Leute hochgeladen haben, weil sie gerade, äh, irgendwie der Meinung waren,
ah ja, ich, ich, ich filme jetzt mal, wo ich hier lang laufe oder so.
Sondern Content, der potenziell auch so gemacht ist und darauf ausgelegt ist, dass er geschaut wird.
Da gibt es viel, viel mehr Content, als Leute den ganzen Kram überhaupt gucken können.
Benutzt du jetzt eigentlich Mikrofon vor deinem Headset?
Ja.
Und wie kommst du drauf?
Excel.
Ich habe mir heute Morgen was überlegt.
Ich habe heute Morgen auf, ähm, dem Tablet ein bisschen rumgeguckt.
Und da wurde mir ein Video empfohlen.
Ein MW2 Speedrun, die gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an, der ist zu lang.
Ähm, sowas hier in der Richtung wurde, wurde mir empfohlen.
Und ich habe mir gedacht, ich frage den Typ einfach mal.
Ob ich mit jemand anderem zusammen seinen Run kommentieren darf bei mir auf YouTube.
Weil ich finde den übelst geil anzugucken.
Ist halt ein bisschen lang jetzt, eineinhalb Stunden.
Und vielleicht, vielleicht will er ja.
Also er selbst wird es nicht können, weil ich glaube nicht, dass er Deutsch spricht.
Aber ich werde den dann ein paar Sachen zu fragen, warum er manche Sachen so macht.
Und dann werden wir uns da mal eineinhalb Stunden zu auslassen.
Ich glaube, das ist recht interessant.
Ich hatte ja auch schon einige Speedrun Videos bei mir auf dem Channel.
Ein bisschen her, ich habe ja auch noch mal nichts mehr gemacht.
Mit wem? Das weiß ich noch nicht genau.
Ja, das weiß man nicht so genau.
Anscheinend, anscheinend.
Also es gehen ja die Gerüchte um, dass YouTube letztens zu wenig Speicher hatte.
Dass sie irgendwelche Quota Probleme mit Speicher hatten für ihr Login System.
Tja, kann sein.
Wir werden es wahrscheinlich nicht erfahren, was wirklich war.
Vielleicht hat auch nur der Falsche aus Versehen auf den falschen Button gedrückt.
Passiert bei den Besten.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Oh Leute, ich bin echt müde noch.
Putzfrau hat gedrückt.
Ich glaube, die Putzfrau kann bei Google nicht viel kaputt machen.
Aber wenn irgendein Techniker oder sonst wie irgendeiner, der halt Zugriff auf irgendwelche Dashboards und sonst was hat, auf den falschen Button drückt, kann vielleicht schon mal was passieren.
So.
Gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Das Cyberbug 20. Oh ne, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Das wird ja schon überall breit gedreht ohne Ende, ey.
Wir können uns das neueste Alpha 4 Games Video angucken.
Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Was Open Worlds 2020 noch von Gothic lernen können.
Ja, es gibt eine Sache.
Ich weiß, wahrscheinlich haben die meisten Leute das Original Gothic gar nicht gespielt.
Also eine Sache, was moderne Spiele wirklich von Gothic lernen können, ist, die sollen In Extremo als Soundtrack reinbauen.
Weiß nicht, hat einer von euch Gothic überhaupt gespielt?
Das Originale.
Da gab es den Auftritt von In Extremo mit halt recht fragwürdigen Animationen.
Also die waren halt schlecht für die heutige Zeit, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ging das?
Irgendwie gickst du immer zusammen.
Also, ähm, ja genau, genau.
Ja, in Gothic 1 gab es In Extremo damals.
Ich glaube, in der Remastered gibt es das nicht mehr, weil sie die Rechte, äh, nicht in der Remastered, was glaube ich denn?
In irgendeiner Gold Edition oder sowas gibt es das dann, glaube ich, nicht mehr, weil sie nicht mehr die Rechte hatten oder sowas.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, das können sie echt lernen.
Komm, das Video gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Mal gucken, was die...
Mal gucken, was die GameStar dazu sagt.
Ach so, und jetzt mal ernsthaft, wenn man mal unabhängig davon, äh, gucken würde, was Open Worlds von Gothic lernen können.
Mal ehrlich, handgecraftete Map größer automatisch generierte Map.
Was bringt mir eine riesen, ultra krasse Map wie in Assassin's Creed Odyssey oder sonst wo, die eigentlich nur langweilig ist?
Klar, Assassin's Creed haben immer ein paar.
Handgecraftete Schauplätze.
Aber das meiste ist halt einfach nur da, damit man irgendwelche Kisten und Collectibles verstecken kann, ohne jeglichen Sinn und Verstand.
Also, handgecraftete Map eindeutig besser als, als riesenrandom generierte Map.
Was man ja auch ein bisschen an Breath of the Wild gesehen hat.
Die haben eine gute Mischung gehabt aus, äh, automatisch generiert, weil die haben sicherlich für Breath of the Wild nicht jeden Hügel und, und jeden Felsen da, äh, von Hand generiert.
Das wäre vielleicht, wie sie, wie sie zu viel des Guten gewesen, ja.
Ähm, aber, äh, viele Sachen in Breath of the Wild waren halt schön, schön von Hand gemacht und deswegen hat sich das auch ganz, hat sich das halt rund angefühlt, ne.
Wie gesagt, ich, ich mochte die Assassin's Creed Sachen, als sie noch zum größten Teil handgemacht waren.
Weiß nicht, wo das aufgehört hat, wahrscheinlich mit Assassin's Creed 3.
Ich habe eigentlich auch schon in Assassin's Creed 2 und den ganzen Ezio Trilogie einiges automatisch generiert, aber vieles war halt da richtig schön gebaut.
Na, ich glaube, wir gucken uns das Video jetzt einfach mal an, was er zu sagen hat.
Ne, habe ich nicht gesehen. Nein, äh, äh, legit, ernsthaft, ich habe das Video nicht gesehen.
Klettern, meucheln, springen, reiten, schleichen, kämpfen, labern, ja, Assassin's Creed war aber schon seine Qualitäten, wobei...
Ey, schockt mich überhaupt nicht. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Normalerweise mag ich dieses Video nicht.
Diese Epoche und auch Wikinger-Gedöns, ja.
Aber Assassin's Creed Valhalla hat mich absolut nicht geschockt.
Ich habe es, ich habe es mir nicht gekauft, nicht mal mit dem Gedanken gespielt, es zu kaufen.
Ehrlich, das trifft auch alles auf die Vorgänger zu. Und The Witcher. Und...
Ah, exzellent. Okay, fangen wir jetzt nochmal von vorne an. Vollbild.
Assassin's Creed 2 beste, ja. Der Ezio war schon, war schon nice.
Ja, Assassin's Creed Valhalla hat schon seine Qualitäten.
Wobei, seien wir doch mal ehrlich, das trifft auch alles auf die Vorgänger zu. Und The Witcher.
Ja, nur dass ich die Vorgänger fast noch besser fand, als es halt noch Assassin's Creed war.
Und nicht historisches RPG mit 50 Milliarden Elementen, um die Spielzeit zu strecken.
Und Ghost of Tsushima. Und Skyrim.
Und der Punkt ist, dass viele Open-World-Titel mittlerweile doch sehr gleich oder zumindest ähnlich geworden sind.
Und das müsste gar nicht so sein, wie uns der Rollenspiel-Klassiker Gothic aus dem Jahre 2000...
Alter, sah das scheiße aus!
Das könnte sogar schon die grafisch aufgemotzte Variante sein, weil es gibt einen Mod.
Es gibt einen Mod für Gothic 1, der ein bisschen moderne Grafikfunktionen hinzufügt.
Ne, das ist der Mod, das ist nicht der Mod, weil in dem Mod glänzen alle Oberflächen wie verrückt.
Und eins zeigt, noch bevor The Witcher überhaupt mit dem ersten Teil kam...
Das stimmt.
...weil ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob das nicht doch der Mod ist, weil ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die Weitsicht so gut war im Original.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr, ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern.
Die Animation, ihr müsst euch mal die Gothic-Animation angucken, Alter.
...mit dem ersten Teil kam, noch bevor Assassin's Creed startete und noch bevor Open Worlds ihren richtig großen Boom erlebten, erschien das RPG...
Das Kampfsystem in Gothic war schon echt Big Brain, Alter.
...die vom deutschen Ende geklappt hat.
Ja, aber es war geil, es war geil.
Und übrigens, Gothic hat es ja mit den Map-Begrenzungen auch nicht richtig hinbekommen.
Also du konntest zum Beispiel ohne Probleme mit ein bisschen Rumgespringe hier raufspringen.
Und storymäßig war es ja in Gothic so, dass du in so einer magischen Barriere eingeschlossen bist und nicht raus kannst und automatisch gekillt wirst, wenn du raus gehst.
Ja, es sei denn, du bist halt an manchen Stellen gelaufen.
Also du konntest, du konntest...
Man kann übrigens direkt am Anfang rausklitschen, by the way, das machen die im Speedrun.
Aber du konntest auch hier oben hochspringen und dann runterrutschen.
Hier hinten ist dann die Wüste irgendwo, da konntest du dann runterrutschen.
Also, es war schon ziemlich verbuggt, ja.
...Piranha Bytes und war trotz aller Hardware-Anforderungen...
Das Menü, das Menü oder das kaum existente Menü-Inventory-Dings-System, ja.
Die haben halt echt viel probiert mit Gothic, ne.
Du hattest ja auch zig Sachen in der Welt, wo du mit interagieren kannst.
Du konntest jede Fackel anzünden und sowas, also...
...wagwürdigen reinen Tastatursteuerungen, so gut, dass es bis heute eine glühende Community hinter sich versammelt.
Aber es war schon ein geiles Game.
Und das völlig zu Recht.
In Zeiten, in denen wir in nahezu jeder offenen Spielwelt nahezu das Gleiche tun und im Grunde nur Listen abarbeiten, ist ein Blick auf die kleine Strafkolonie von...
Die, die, die Dialoge in Gothic waren halt auch geil.
Die waren, also vor allem auf Deutsch.
Die waren halt schon so, die waren eigentlich richtig schlecht.
Was die Sprecher angeht.
Aber, aber so, so, dass es irgendwie wieder gepasst hat, ja.
Und was halt auch in Gothic geil war, mir fällt jetzt kein spezieller Dialog ein.
Aber wenn du da das Falsche gesagt hast, haben auch die NPCs gesagt, so nach dem Motto, ich hau dir aufs Maul oder sowas.
Das war schon, war eigentlich genau das, was man von so einer Fantasy-Welt erwarten würde.
... mehr als angebracht.
Denn egal, ob nun The Witcher, Ghost of Tsushima oder eben Assassin's Creed.
Gothic zeigt exemplarisch, welche einfachen Kniffe und Tugenden das Genre verlernt hat und wiederentdecken sollte.
Welche genau, das erfahrt ihr hier.
Dafür schauen wir uns die Begrenzung von...
Hier, hier, hier war das In Extremo-Konzert, Leute.
Wer kennt's noch?
Hier, genau hier, oder?
Doch, ziemlich sicher. Hier war, glaub ich, das In Extremo-Konzert später.
Da haben sie dann irgendwie, ähm, einen Sänger und zwei Tänzerinnen oder so auf die Bühne gestellt.
Ein bisschen Publikum vorne dran.
Und, und haben dann...
In Extremo-Musik MP3 gedoodelt.
... die Orientierung darin und die Verknüpfung mit dem Gameplay an und zeigen,
wieso diese eigentlich sehr kleinen Designentscheidungen eine große Auswirkung haben können.
Und das alles anhand des Beispiels Gothic.
Und klar, nicht jedes Element hat das RPG selbst etabliert, nicht alles taucht exklusiv hier auf.
Es dient vielmehr als Beispiel für eine Art Open World, die heutzutage kaum noch jemand zu kennen scheint.
Das Kampfsystem.
Wenn man nicht gerade Flight Simulator 2020 heißt, steht man als Open World vor einem grundsätzlichen Problem.
Offen ja, endlos nein.
Selbst die schönste Karte muss irgendwo aufhören, anders sind die riesigen Gebiete gar nicht zu helfen.
Ey, ich finde, das hat Breath of the Wild tatsächlich ganz gut gelöst.
Die haben das gar nicht versteckt.
Breath of the Wild hat einfach gesagt, hier ist die Welt zu Ende.
Das war's, fertig. Hier ist die Welt zu Ende.
Ja, und du wurdest dann zurückgepustet.
Also, insofern, die haben es gar nicht versucht zu verschleiern.
Es sei denn, man setzt auf die Technik von... genau.
Also gibt es mehrere Möglichkeiten, die Grenzen der offenen Welt plausibel zu erklären.
Die einfachste Methode ist, eine Insel zu nehmen, wie etwa Ghost of Tsushima.
Dann gibt es natürliche Barrieren und fertig.
Blöd wird das nur, wenn wir in einer Metropole unterwegs sind, die eigentlich auf dem Festland liegen sollte.
Andere Alternativen sind unpassierbare Berge, volle Straßen und eine unsichtbare Welt.
Oder, oder, oder nicht zu vergessen, Call of Duty Logik.
Sie verlassen das Schlachtfeld, kehren sie um.
Das ist die Call of Duty Logik, die ist so richtig schlecht.
Eigentlich ist die Call of Duty Logik, was World Borders angeht, so mega kacke.
So nach dem Motto, ja, da geht doch die Straße lang und da vorne ist was.
Nein, nein, sie verlassen das Kampfgebiet, drehen sie um.
Das ist ein vermeintlich kleines Problem, ja.
Einmal gelöst, bereichert es aber die gesamte Erfahrung.
Und wie macht man das nun? Na, indem man zum Beispiel den Nach in einen Vorteil verwandelt.
Gothic hat die Begrenzung einfach aufgenommen und als Teil der Welt etabliert.
Der Kern des Spiels dreht sich um das Leben in einem Gefängnis.
Nichts anderes passiert hier. Wir landen in einer Strafkolonie und die muss...
Boah, ey, das würden sie heute wahrscheinlich nicht mehr zeigen.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Im Intro, im Intro von Gothic 1, dann wirst du ja in dieses Gefängnis runtergefahren, so.
Und, und, wenn man runtergefahren auf so einem, auf so einem Minifahrstuhl ist da, auf so einem Holz, auf so einer Holzrutsche werden die runtergefahren.
Und da liegt auch so eine halbnackte Frau drauf, das hätten die heute garantiert nicht mehr im Intro drin.
Also nicht, nicht weil es eine halbnackte Frau ist, sondern weil die damit indirekt quasi sagen wollten,
dass die sich quasi Frauen da irgendwie als Sklaven runterfahren lassen in das Gefängnis.
Das wäre heute definitiv monka-tost. Das Thema würden die garantiert nicht mehr aufgreifen.
...irgendwie zusammengehalten werden und zwar von einer magischen Barriere.
Es ist ein einfacher, aber effektiver Kniff.
Was in dem Setting, was in dem Setting aber passt.
Weil die Levelgrenze nun auch innerhalb der Welt Logik besitzt, bricht die Immersion für uns selbst am Ende der Open World nicht.
Lektion 1 ist also, die notwendige Begrenzung der Welt sollte Teil des Spiels sein.
Das erinnert uns immer wieder etwas daran, dass wir eben doch nur ein Spiel spielen.
Wie gut das funktionieren kann, zeigt sogar die Assassin's Creed-Reihe.
Hier gehen die erlebten Erinnerungen eben nicht weiter. Einfach, aber nachvollziehbar.
Ja, das stimmt. Das haben sie gut gemacht.
Die Straßen im Deus Ex Human Revolution sind hingegen ein viel zu unglaubwürdiger Zufall.
Immortals Fenyx Rising ist wiederum als reiner Spaßort angelegt.
Da passt eine Insel als Begrenzung wie die Faust aufs Auge.
Der Kontext ist also nicht ganz ohne.
Dennoch kann so eine Kleinigkeit wie die logische Begrenzung der offenen Spielwelt
doch deutlich ein Atmosphäre-Plus bedeuten.
Da habe ich mir nie Gedanken drüber gemacht. Eigentlich ist das richtig Big Brain bei Gothic gewesen,
dass sie gesagt haben, okay, die Barriere gehört zur Story. Eigentlich ziemlich clever.
Was Gothic neben dem ersten Kniff ebenfalls wie kein zweiter Titel verstanden hat,
ist der Aufbau der eigenen Welt sowie die Orientierung darin.
Heutzutage ist es völlig normal, auf eine Minimap oder einen Kompass zu schauen,
sich einfach eine Markierung ins Land zu setzen und schnurstracks auf direktem Wege dorthin zu lenken oder zu reiten.
Questmarker, lol, weh.
Ey, die hätten lieber ihr eigenes Game nicht fertiggestellt, damals wahrscheinlich, anstatt Questmarker einzubauen.
Oder nicht Questmarker, also Pfeile, wo es lang geht.
Das gab's nicht. Da gab's das Banditenlager im Westen und solche Dinger gab's dann.
Da gab's kein Pfeil.
... und die Beschaffenheit der Umgebung schnell auszublenden, weil die Landschaft eigentlich...
By the way, by the way, dazu muss ich jetzt sagen, da ist es ung... also wenn man,
wenn man eine automatisch generierte Spielwelt hat, die sich eben auch ein bisschen so anfühlt,
halt eben keine logischen Punkte, die man sich gut merken kann,
dann ist es natürlich wichtig, dass man Questmarker und Questpfeile hat und sowas in der Richtung,
weil sonst findet man's nicht.
Hat man eine Spielwelt, die irgendwie logisch aufgebaut ist, hat man eine Spielwelt, die man sich gut merken kann,
dann kommt man auch anhand der Beschreibung von NPCs ganz gut zurecht, wo man hin muss.
Und ich finde, man merkt einfach den Unterschied zwischen handgecrafteter Welt,
oder zumindest in Großteilen handgecrafteter Welt und zum größten Teil automatisch generierter Welt.
Weil in Großteilen automatisch generierter Welt findet man sich nicht zurecht,
in handgecrafteter Welt findet man sich zurecht.
Das sieht man, finde ich, ganz gut bei etwas älteren MMOs.
Ich kann beispielsweise in Dark Age of Camelot, kann ich vom Anfang der Welt ans Ende der Welt quasi laufen,
ähm, ohne dass ich irgendwie eine Map oder sowas brauche.
Überhaupt kein Problem. Einfach weil's einprägsam gewesen ist.
... im nächsten Ort steht.
Aber dieser Weg ist essentieller Bestandteil von Open-World-Spielen.
Oder sollte es vielmehr sein?
Bei Gothic fehlen Hinweise zu Richtung Standort und mehr komplett.
Wir müssen anderen Figuren genau zuhören, wohin wir eigentlich müssen.
Wenn wir uns ohne Kompass und nur mit Beschreibungen von A nach B bewegen können,
macht das Spiel sehr viel richtig.
Wo finde ich das alte Lager?
Du musst nur dem Weg hier folgen.
Wo wohnt der Kartenzeichner Greyhound?
Der wohnt drüben, links, neben dem Nordturm.
Für all das benötigen wir nie einen Kompass, weil wir uns in der Welt selbst perfekt zurechtfinden können.
Und das liegt gleich an zwei Sachen.
Zum einen ist die Minenkolonie clever aufgebaut.
Wir gehen zu Beginn hier herunter und sehen direkt das erste interessante Ziel vor Augen.
Auch führen Wege sehr klar durch die Landschaft und immer wieder reizen uns Gebäude und Ruinen zum Erkunden.
Wobei die Gegnerstärke eine natürliche Grenze innerhalb des begrenzten Gefängnisses darstellen.
Wir brauchen keine Karte oder ähnliches,
um zu den vielen Punkten hinzuwollen.
Das Spiel führt uns etwa zu Beginn mit einem klar erkennbaren Pfad oder Hinweisen von anderen Menschen selbst dorthin.
Zum anderen legt es, genau wie bei der Grenze, wieder einmal die Navigation in die Spielwelt selbst.
Angefangen bei den Beschreibungen der Mithäftlinge, die uns wirklich weiterhelfen und nicht bloß einen Punkt auf der Karte offenbaren.
Und selbst die Karte existiert als Gegenstand in der Welt und die müssen wir uns dann auch erst einmal leisten können.
Zusätzlich hält das Spiel zwar Quests und Lehrer fest,
aber fügt nie zusätzliche Informationen hinzu.
Wir klicken hier nicht einfach auf einer Liste Missionen durch und markieren sie auf der Karte.
Wir müssen selbst herausfinden, mit wem wir sprechen und wo wir als nächstes am besten hingehen.
Assassin's Creed und sogar das hervorragende The Witcher 3 sehen dagegen alt aus.
Klar, in Städten oder an markanten Orten wissen wir ungefähr, wo wir sind.
Weil wir aber niemals wirklich dazu genötigt wurden, mit Hinweisen in unserem eigenen Spiel zu gehen.
Da hat er voll und ganz recht, genau das.
Es gibt ganz viele Regionen, die wir wieder vergessen.
Wie diesen Weg oder diesen Berg.
Das liegt aber, wie gesagt, meiner Meinung nach liegt es auch daran,
klar, wenn du immer nur Questmarkern hinterher rennst, das ist das eine,
aber die Welt ist halt nicht logisch handgecraftet aufgebaut.
Weil man darf nicht vergessen, eine Sache, wo wir wirklich gut drin sind, ist,
also auch hirnmäßig, evolutionsmäßig,
wir sind wirklich gut darin, Zusammenhänge zu erkennen in Sachen.
Auch total unterbewusst nebenbei.
Das heißt, irgendwas handgecraftet ist immer einprägsamer, als was random generiert ist.
Big-Brain-Logik, ja.
... deutlich nützlicher, weil wir uns sonst zu oft verlaufen könnten,
aber das ändert nichts daran, dass das eigentliche Navigieren hier keine Herausforderung mehr ist
und uns so weniger an den Schauplatz fesselt.
Und dass das kein Ding der Unmöglichkeit ist, zeigt beispielsweise The Legend of Zelda Breath of the Wild.
So sieht's aus.
Aber sowohl ist die Karte ein Gegenstand der Welt,
als auch finden wir über besondere Architekturen und Hinweise von Personen unsere Ziele.
Die Fortbewegung und Erkundung selbst machen dadurch viel mehr Spaß.
Lektion 2 schließt damit direkt an die erste an,
das Zurechtfinden in der Open World ist eine Kernkompetenz des Genres
und sollte daher ebenfalls direkt in die Welt integriert sein.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Sonst wird sie zu anspruchslos und verkommt zur Geduldsprobe, anstatt...
Das ist doch übelst langweilig, wenn du die ganze Zeit nur Questmarkern nachrennst.
Gameplay.
Ja, scheiß...
Das ist aber auch nur, weil die Welt da wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil auch noch handcrafted ist.
Ich finde mich in MMOs, die ich lang gespielt habe, auch blind zurecht.
Aber auch nur, weil man eben die Welt richtig erkunden musste.
Und weil man nicht permanent nur Questmarkern hinterhergerannt ist.
Wie das bei aktuellen Addons aussieht, keine Ahnung.
Die aber wohl wichtigste Frage,
die sich jedes potenzielle Open-World-Spiel stellen sollte, ist...
Was war das nochmal für ein Game?
Ah, das ist Dings hier, PS4-Exclusive-Dings gewesen.
Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt.
Wie hieß denn das nochmal?
PS4-Exclusive, das weiß ich noch. Irgend so ein Zombie-Game.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht Last of Us.
Das ist das mit diesem Motorrad-Ding.
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, wie es heißt.
Das war mal irgendwie... Days Gone!
Ja, das kann sein.
Das war mal irgendwie zwei Wochen angesagt, dann hat es keinen mehr interessiert.
Aber an vielen Stellen kann man sehr gut dafür argumentieren,
dass einige der letzten großen Produktionen, wie etwa Days Gone,
diese Frage ganz ehrlich mit Nein beantworten müssten.
Bleiben wir doch bei diesem Beispiel.
Days Gone erzählt eine Geschichte in einer Zombie-Apokalypse.
Es gibt verschiedene Story-Stränge, es gibt verschiedene Lager
und eine sehr offene Karte.
Zombie-Apokalypse ist richtig Resident-Sleeper.
Die Lager nehmen keine besondere Rolle ein
und in der Open-World reisen wir nur von einem Punkt zum anderen.
Man könnte auch einfach alle Missionen und ein paar Nebenaktivitäten nehmen,
und sie ohne Probleme in ein lineares Abenteuer
à la The Last of Us stecken.
Denn wirklich Gebrauch von seiner offenen Welt
macht Days Gone so gut wie nie.
Außer eben, dass wir mit dem Motorrad darin herumfahren
und Zombies ab und zu treffen.
Und da ist Gothic, ob ihr es glaubt oder nicht,
das perfekte Gegenbeispiel.
Hier gibt es ebenfalls verschiedene Lager und Story-Stränge,
nur brauchen die die offene Welt auch.
Zum einen sind die Gruppierungen hier allesamt
in der Story-Fahrenkarte und logisch entstanden.
Gut, das trifft auch für die in Days Gone zu.
Allerdings fungieren sie hier als Missionspunkte nicht mehr.
Held Deacon St. John schließt sich hin und wieder in den Fraktionen an,
aber immer genau gleich, so wie es die Story eben will.
Gothic legt diese Entscheidung in unsere Hände.
Wir selbst schauen uns die Gebiete an,
wir selbst legen Prüfungen ab und suchen uns dann selbst aus,
wo wir hin möchten.
Holistik, ich finde, das hängt schon ein bisschen davon ab,
wie das Game aufgebaut ist.
Und zwar, siehst du, in Witcher 3 hat man es ganz gut gesehen.
Witcher 3 war auch ein Game,
mehr oder weniger, zumindest bei den Side-Quests,
konntest du Questmarkern nachrennen.
So, und wenn man quasi die Novigrad-Quests gemacht hat
und nur die Questmarker nachgerannt ist,
du kanntest dich in der Stadt nicht wirklich aus, ja?
Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch gegangen ist,
aber ich hatte total oft das Problem,
wenn ich nach Novigrad rein oder gerade raus musste,
weil ich zu einer anderen Quest musste,
ich habe oftmals den nächstgelegenen Ausgang nicht gefunden,
weil ich schlicht und ergreifend keine Orientierung in der Stadt hatte,
wo was ist.
Wäre ich da normal durchgelaufen,
hätte mir das Ganze besser eingeprägt,
weil ich nicht sinnlos Questmarkern nachgerannt wäre,
dann hätte ich mich da besser aus.
Da hätte ich sofort gewusst, wo es lang geht,
wo es zum Hafen geht, wo es hier wohin geht, sonst wo.
Aber wenn du nur Questmarkern nachrennst,
du lernst den Kram einfach nicht.
Und du musst die Leute tatsächlich dazu zwingen, das zu machen,
weil wenn du die Auswahl hast zwischen Questmarker und keine Questmarker,
irgendwo hast du immer das Gefühl,
wenn du Questmarker quasi ausblendest,
so nach dem Motto, die Quests sind ja vielleicht gar nicht dafür designed,
für ohne Questmarker und sowas,
was sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht sind, wenn es Questmarker gibt.
...offen, sondern auch unser Weg darin.
Und das fördert den Sinn und Zweck einer Open World immens.
Lektion 3 lautet daher,
eine offene Welt sollte sich positiv aufs Gameplay auswirken
und nicht bloß eine Kulisse
für ein paar Missionen und Aktivitäten sein.
Entscheidungen und unterschiedliche Wege
können dieses Gefühl verdammt gut vermitteln.
Bring mich zu eurem Lager, das will ich mir ansehen.
Sehr gut. Ich werde vorangehen, folge mir.
Fassen wir also noch einmal zusammen.
Ja, aber 1.09, wie auch immer, da brauchst du ja auch kein Open World.
Da kannst du einfach Schlauchlevel machen.
Viele Standards in Open Worlds
haben sich in den letzten Jahren herausgebildet,
um uns ein möglichst stressfreies und angenehmes Leben
in den Weiten der Welten zu garantieren.
Dabei vergessen viele Spieler aber,
dass eben die Freiheit einer offenen Welt
mit einigen Überwindungen
und Herausforderungen verbunden ist.
Am immersivsten löst ein Spiel das,
indem es all diese Hindernisse
in die Spielwelt selbst hineinlegt.
Das macht die Begrenzungen glaubhafter
und die Navigation intuitiver und spannender.
Vor allem aber sollte es seine Open Worlds entspannen.
Oh nein, oh nein, oh nein.
In Gothic konnte man ja auch klettern und springen und sowas.
Das war auch so ein Ding für sich.
Man konnte hier, das ist übrigens ganz am Anfang,
man konnte hier hoch und so.
Die Gothic-Spring-Animation.
...Kulisse begreifen, sondern Kontext zwischen sich
und den Geschehnissen auf allen Ebenen schaffen.
Wobei, das war noch eine gute Kletter-Animation.
Die Hochspring-Animation, wo er so die Hände hochmacht,
die sieht ganz grausam aus.
Das Erkunden selbst sollte gefördert werden
und wir sollten nur die nötigsten Informationen nachgucken können,
weil wir sonst einfach nur stumpf
die altbekannten Listen abarbeiten.
Wie findest du Gothic 2?
Du meinst Red Dead Redemption 2?
Habe ich nicht gespielt.
Der einzige auf der Welt, der das nicht gespielt hat, glaube ich.
Oh, hier.
Das, was man eben sieht, ist das Remake.
Outcast, Outcast war richtig Poggers.
Das ist übrigens das Outcast-Remake,
wo man, glaube ich zumindest,
das sieht viel zu gut aus für das ursprüngliche Outcast.
Das ursprüngliche Outcast hatte eine richtig geile Spielwelt damals.
Ups.
...eine ähnliche Kerbe.
Im Spielstatus haben sich beide Titel
auch wegen dieser kleinen Kniffe redlich verdient.
Unsere herausgearbeiteten Lehren
wirken sich sehr positiv aufs Spielgefühl einer eigenen Welt aus.
Ah, yes.
Herausgearbeitete Lehren von der GameStar.
Excellent.
Sie alle würden von mehr Verbindung
zwischen Gebiet, Gameplay und Geschichte profitieren.
Und so aus hübschen, aber irgendwie...
Cyberpunk schon gespielt?
Nee, da habe ich erst mal einen Bogen drum gemacht.
...Gesellschaften erschaffen.
Wenn ihr noch mehr zu Assassin's Creed seht...
Ähm...
Ort namens Poggersdorf.
Ja, es gibt auch in Österreich ein Dorf,
was sich Fucking nennt.
Wollten die sich jetzt nicht angeblich umbenennen?
Österreich Fucking?
Fucking?
Fucking ist ein Ortsteil in der...
Was für einem Ding?
Katastralgemeinde Hofstadt.
Der gemeinte Tarsdorf im Bezirk Braunau am Inn
in Oberösterreich. Fucking.
Der Ortsname im öffentlichen Interesse.
Heißt nun Fugging.
Haha.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so viel besser ist,
ob das Fucking Fugging heißt.
Wie ist das? Fugging?
Ah, hier. Umbenennung.
Zum 1. Januar 2011 Fugging umzubenennen.
Aber wisst ihr was?
Ich glaube, das ist Fail.
Da sind doch bestimmt total viele Leute hingegangen.
Einfach nur, weil es Fucking heißt, oder?
Also, es gibt doch zig Videos von irgendwelchen
Amis und sonstigen Sachen,
die sich darüber lustig gemacht haben,
dass das Ding Fucking heißt.
Nicht, dass die sich
ins eigene Fleisch damit schneiden,
dass sie sich in Fugging
anstatt Fucking umbenannt haben.
Die haben das Ortsschild geklaut. Ernsthaft?
Die haben das Ortsschild geklaut?
Alter, die Leute, ey.
So Fail.
Ich hab gedacht, die Leute hätten mal wenigstens Urlaub
in Fugging gemacht. Oder in Fuckingen.
Oder...
Könnt ihr hier unseren Test zum neuesten Teil
von HALA anschauen?
Außerdem lohnt es sich nach wie vor auf unseren
Geburtstagsrückblick zur Gothic-Serie zu schauen,
in dem der Sprecher dieses Videos
übrigens auch dabei ist.
Oh, exzellent. Aber das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Sehr schön.
Musik anmachen.
Ja, aber es...
wird schon...
merkwürdig, ne?
Es ist doch gut. Ey, wisst ihr?
Belle Delphine verkauft
Gamer Girl Badewasser und Zeug,
um bekannt zu werden
und sonst was, ja? Und die hier
machen das Gegenteil. Die sind schon
bekannt, weil sie Fucking heißen und da benennen sie sich
einfach um in Fugging.
Das ist doch bescheuert.
Was macht die eigentlich?
Irgendwie ist da...
Irgendwie interessiert sich keiner mehr
wirklich für Belle Delphine, oder?
Wollte die nicht Ende des Jahres
irgendeinen Porn rausbringen?
Ich weiß, ich weiß,
dass nur... Chat, Chat, ich weiß, dass nur
weil der Discord
mir das erzählt hat. Sonst, sonst
weiß ich sowas natürlich nicht.
Wie gesagt, die Info.
Das benutzte Kondom will sie verkaufen auf Reddit.
Oh, meine Frist. Eins muss man
echt sagen, ohne Scheiß.
Die hat Marketing komplett durchgespielt,
was das angeht.
Und wisst ihr, wer auch das komplett durchgespielt
hat?
MrBeast hat den Kram
auch komplett durchgespielt. MrBeast
hat jetzt ne Burgerkette aufgemacht.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Ja, das ist ne Burgerkette
mit irgendwie 300 Restaurants
in den USA und angeblich
hatten die irgendwie hunderte Meter
Schlangen davor, um
sich den MrBeast-Burger
zu holen.
Der macht das richtig.
Der lässt nichts anbrennen.
Da sind die Stonks real.
Mein Typ ist ja jetzt schon wahrscheinlich
multimillionär, aber spätestens jetzt
ist er wahrscheinlich multi-multi-multi-
millionär.
Also, richtig big brain.
Wie öffnet man 300 Läden auf einmal?
Indem man 300 Läden gleichzeitig spaut
und dann 300 Läden an einem Tag aufmacht.
Und indem man Geld hat. Wobei er das sicherlich
nicht privat bezahlt hat.
Was für ein Mikrofon? Ich hab immer noch
seit acht Jahren oder so,
hab ich dieses Headset
und aktuell verwende ich auch dieses Headset mit Mikrofon.
Und dann hab ich auch schon seit ungefähr
acht Jahren so ein Ding, USB-Mikro,
mit dem ich manchmal was aufnehme.
Total so ein olles.
Ja, gute Frage.
Zeig mal her, ob ich da was zu sagen kann.
Oh, ich brauche deine Hilfe.
Ich suche einen Serveranbieter, der mindestens
vier Terabyte Speicher anbietet
für meine Backups. Ach so, Backups.
Okay, Backups. Das heißt, du brauchst
eigentlich nichts großartiges.
Du brauchst einfach nur Speicher.
Wie sieht's
Chat? Vielleicht wisst ihr das.
Ich weiß es nicht, aber es war früher eine Zeit
lang so ein Geheimtipp. Es gab
so einen Google
Drive
Upgrade Plan, der
ziemlich günstig war. Ne, ne,
AWS und sowas. Wenn man einfach nur Sachen backuppen will,
da ist das viel zu teuer. Ich würde, ich würde
irgendwie so ein Low-Budget
Storage-Server
irgendwie mal suchen.
Ach, Google Unlimited gibt's nicht mehr.
Okay.
Ja, dann. Ich müsste, wie gesagt,
ich müsste mich mit Offsite-Backup auch mal
beschäftigen. Was gibt's? Komm, wir gucken
jetzt mal. Low-End
Storage.Win.
Klingt sehr vertrauenserweckend.
Ah, ne.
Das ist so eine Übersichtsseite. Okay, zeigt
mal her. Was gibt's da?
Storage.
Aber, aber
3T.
3T für 10 Euro. Wobei, das
kriegt man woanders auch.
Oder? Cheap Storage.
Okay, also ich kann dir nicht
sagen, was die allerbilligste Sache ist.
Schauen wir mal, was
die, also Hetzner
Cloud dürfte ein bisschen zu teuer sein, rein was
Speicher angeht, wenn man das nur für Speicher
braucht.
Guck, die haben,
die haben sowas Großes gar nicht.
Du kannst 5T dranhängen, das kostet
dann nur, nur zusätzlich
250 Euro.
Wir können mal bei der Hetzner
Server-Auktion gucken.
Was es da gibt.
Äh, mindestens
4. Oh, wie sie teuer.
Das kriegt man garantiert billiger.
Wenn man ein bisschen sucht.
Was haben die hier bei Storage?
Storage Box. Excellent.
Was haben wir hier?
5T für
6T. Okay, da wird's schon ein bisschen billiger.
Das ist, das ist tatsächlich
ganz okay.
Aber das lohnt sich, finde ich, auch nur,
wenn man irgendwie noch ein bisschen was anderes machen will
auf den Kisten. Ansonsten wäre es mir ein bisschen teuer.
Strato High Drive.
Strato, Alter, gibt's die noch?
Strato.
Ja, nee, also kann ich dir jetzt nichts Gutes raten.
Aber Offside Backup ist auch so ein Thema,
mit dem ich mich unbedingt noch beschäftigen muss.
Das gucken wir uns als nächstes an.
Komm, wir gucken uns, wir gucken uns eine Runde
Lockpicking an.
Oder Flirtbots auf Instagram.
Nein, nein, nein. Chat,
Chat, ich weiß, was wir uns angucken.
Das müssen wir uns angucken.
Was ist das schlechteste
Twitch-Emote?
Okay, also.
Bevor wir das Video gucken,
ich sag euch jetzt mal, meine zwei
Hass-Emotes
auf Twitch.
Also zwei Sachen, die ich überhaupt nicht mag.
Und auch wenn ich immer sag,
dass lulwee größer kekwee ist,
ähm,
oder sagen wir mal drei Emotes, die ich nicht mag.
Ich hab kein Problem mit kekwee und lulwee.
Also, ich mag jepp nicht,
das stimmt, Crash Fluffy, jepp.
Und was ich nicht,
was ich sonst noch nicht mag, ist
haha, haha
mag ich nicht. Und was ich
überhaupt nicht mag, ist das hier, Chat.
Guck mal.
Pogo, Pogo mag ich nicht.
Pogo haben wir nur im Chat,
weil der Chat sich das gewünscht hat.
Aber jepp, jepp ist
ehrlich gesagt so das Emote, was
mir am meisten auf den Sack geht.
Und Pogo mag ich auch nicht, aber
Pogo und
haha, aber jepp ist so das
nervigste, finde ich.
Twitch-Chat, one of the biggest enigmas
of modern history.
Also, ich kenne die alle nicht.
Den kenne ich, das ist Asmongold.
Wer ist denn die anderen Dudes?
Ich kenn mich da nicht aus.
Ich hab bei Twitch-Streamer auch langsam
echt den Anschluss verloren.
...
Der Typ, der Typ
im, äh, das ist laut
genug das Video. Der Typ im Discord ist einfach nur leise.
Der Typ im Discord, ne?
Das ist quasi Twitch-CHAT
Live in Reallife.
Hört euch den Depp mal an!
Das ist wirklich, das ist Twitch Chat mit im Discord. Richtig dumme.
Why the fuck was that guy so mean?
What is the absolute worst Twitch emote on the platform?
Sagt doch, was?
I would say KekW. I mean KekW might be up there.
KekW is probably the worst one out there.
Was? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Das kann nicht sein.
Way too quickly, right? It's so easy to spam KekW. You see it everywhere.
You probably want me to say KekW. Probably do. But I'm not gonna say what you want me to say. I'm gonna say LolW.
Was? Noch schlimmer?
Also, also, KekW lasse ich mir noch gefallen, aber LolW? Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Oh, what is your least favorite Twitch emote on the platform?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Um, the robot sad one.
Was für ein Ding?
Please remove Jepp from your chatroom.
Jepp, jawoll. Jepp muss weg. Jepp suckt.
Haha.
Jawoll. Sehe ich auch so.
Haha ist echt Cancer, ey.
It's gotta be Haha. That's an easy pick.
Right now, I hate Drake.
Alrighty, everyone. I'm sitting here with...
Tom Van.
What is the worst trashcan, godawful Twitch emote on the platform? What do you think it is?
Emotes that, like, takes away the uniqueness of a chat. Let's take, for example, KekW.
Now, now, I am not a KekW hater, because everyone hates it.
I don't like it, because it takes away the uniqueness. Every single moment becomes a KekW.
So you don't see as much LOLWs, Pepe Laughs, you know, the other laugh emotes.
Oh, jetzt wird's aber, jetzt wird's aber philosophisch.
Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden hab, er sagt, er mag KekW nicht, weil jeder Moment, der lustig ist, der normalerweise sein eigenes Emote hätte, jetzt KekW ist.
Ah, verstehe. Verstehe. Exquisite Logik.
By the way, ich möchte jetzt hier nochmal eine Sache klarstellen, ja.
Ich bin 36, sitze Sonntag 10.50 Uhr vorm Rechner und philosophiere mit euch drüber, was besser ist.
Und ob KekW nicht, äh, die anderen Emotes auf Twitch irgendwie...
Ja.
KekWs beste.
KekW, by far. Fuck that, you know.
KekW?
KekW.
Uh, you know what, KekW, that's it.
KekW, easy.
Alter, was habt ihr alle gegen KekW?
I'd say, I'd say it's KekW.
Es wird mal Zeit, dass einer KekTripleU macht.
I'll be honest.
Mmm, want me to keep it a stack?
You can keep it a stack, you can keep it a stack and a half.
I...
KekW, bro.
Kek.
W.
Alright, I'm here with...
MD.
And what is the worst Twitch Emote on the platform?
Okay, so this is kind of an easy question.
So, KekW is the worst Emote in the history of the universe
and it needs to be banished from every chatroom.
You said, what's the worst Emote?
Yeah, the worst Twitch Emote.
LolW.
Oha.
Also, okay, okay, Leute.
KekW kann ich ja noch verstehen, ja.
Aber, aber was zum Toi...
Was kann man denn gegen, gegen LulW haben?
LolW ist doch, ist doch eigentlich das beste Lach-Emote überhaupt.
Also, LolW ist noch besser als Lol.
Weil, wisst ihr auch warum?
Weil Lol gar nicht mehr das originale Lol-Emote ist
und LolW ist das originale Lol-Emote, allerdings rangezoomt.
Man, man versteht, was ich meine, ne?
Also, guckt euch mal im Chat an.
Lol ist das nachgemalte, weil TotalBiscuit nicht mal mehr die Rechte am eigenen Gesicht hatte, quasi.
Und, ähm, LolW ist das rangezoomte Original-Lol.
Und deswegen bin ich ja immer noch der Meinung, L, LL, UL ist größer als LUL.
Ja?
Alles klar, Chat?
Könnt ihr mir folgen?
Alles klar, gut, weiter.
Warum wurde da schon wieder gebannt?
Smorg.
Smorg?
Smorg, das letzte Emote, an das ich gedacht hätte, ist Smorg, also.
ulos Smorg, alder.
Obwohl hey, ich dehne das wirklich so lange.
So viel.
Ich glaube, dass ich nicht mehr ganz diesen haben möchte.
Ich versuche nicht mal echt lustig zu sein.
Ich finde, dass ich keinen wirklich.
P ради.
Es ist nur an Racesport genutzt.
Es gibt keinen im Welt ist stimmt.
außer bei Snitches.
Aber das mein, du weißt, wie ich meine, ich meine, x, nein, tripod, manchmal ist es gar nicht lagi, es ist solidartig,
immer nur nur die Racesport unterschieden,
als alles drin.
Danny?
Z tableau, free entertainment?
Racebait, and it gets a little old, and people who say that it's not, it is, that's just kind of how it is.
But I don't think it should be removed, I just think that it's the worst because it's used that way.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Oh, was?
You know the III?
The League Emote?
Yeah, that shit.
You're the fucking hype man.
Fungineer.
What?
Das ist das Emote, hab ich vergessen, dass das überhaupt existiert.
Definitely the worst Emote on Twitch.
I hate Pog though, I hate Pog.
Pog ist Pog.
Pepe Pains, disgusting Emote.
Pepe Pains.
Oh wait, that's actually easy bro, Pepe Pains.
What?
Fucking hate Pepe Pains.
Um, come on bro.
Honestly, it's probably Haha.
Ja, sehe ich auch so, Haha sagt, das kenne ich gar nicht.
Pains Champs, they're just toxic, and unnecessary.
Weird Champ.
Four weird.
Uh, LOLW, KW is better.
My least favorite Twitch Emotes would probably be...
Wie, heyguys.
Um, right now I guess Pog-O.
Ja, Pog-O mag ich auch nicht.
Pog-O.
I don't know, every fucking pipe train Emote.
I am not a fan of Omega LOL.
It's unpopular opinion.
Mmmmm, Omega LOL.
Pepe.
You laugh kinda annoying, not gonna lie.
Beste, ich mag das.
He, he lacks critical information.
Das, ich mag das Emote, ja.
Ah, Pog-O mag ich nicht.
Like, come on bro, or something like that.
LOLW.
What is your least favorite Twitch Emote?
Anything with peep.
Peep?
Anything with peep?
Peep, Pepe.
Twitch Emote?
Like, like the rapper?
No.
Oh, you don't like, oh, Pepe.
Oh, oh, oh.
Was war das jetzt?
Alter, was war das jetzt am Schluss?
Fuck.
Hat er da seine Schwester interviewt, oder was?
Ja.
Ha, ha.
Haha.
And tied for third place we have Pepe Pains and come on, bruh.
I hope you all enjoy-
Und wo ist Pog-O?
Warum ist Pog-O nicht dabei?
Also, haha, geh ich mit.
Kack, eh, eh, also hier, eh, ne?
Haha, geh ich mit, aber der Rest nicht.
Ask Twitch Chat.
The top three most disliked Emotes were Kek, W, haha.
Ja, voll, voll einverstanden mit haha, sucked, Kack Emote.
And tied for third place we have Pepe Pains and come on, bruh.
Nö
POG-O-Filter
Yep
Und POG-O müssen da noch rein
Nee, Kussi, eigentlich haben glaube ich nur
Drei Leute POG-O gesagt oder so
Ups, wow, ich wollte das jetzt gar nicht
Nochmal starten
Nee, also, da gehe ich nicht mit
Also, ich
Ich lasse es mir gefallen
Dass HH drin ist, das ist gut
KekW überhaupt nicht
Weirdchamp schon mal gar nicht
Äh, Command Bra
Okay, ja, kann man sich drüber streiten
Aber, aber, dass da nicht POG-O drin ist
Oder zumindest, oder zumindest mal
Yep, kann nicht sein
Ja, Dislike ist raus, bam
Ich dislike eigentlich aus Prinzip
Keine Videos
Ich glaube, ich habe, ist jetzt kein Witz, ne
Ich habe insgesamt, seit ich
Auf YouTube bin, vielleicht, sag mal mal
Fünf Videos disliked oder so
Ich mache das eigentlich anders
Wenn ich ein Video nicht mag, mache ich es einfach
Instant aus, fertig
Ich dislike eigentlich keine Videos
Außer es ist irgendwas, was ich
Was mir, wo ich die Leute
Überhaupt nicht abkann
Und, ähm, ich es laufend empfohlen kriege
Dann vielleicht, aber ansonsten
Oh
Oh, kurz ein bisschen Musik wieder an
Äh, also, was ich disliked habe
Was ich weiß, als wo du es hier gerade
Sagst, also, was ich disliked
Habe, war der
Diablo Immortal Trailer
Den habe ich disliked
Das weiß ich noch
Da habe ich mitgemacht
Aber ansonsten
Was habe ich denn sonst noch disliked
Ich kann mich nur an den Diablo Immortal Trailer erinnern
Den ich disliked habe
Ansonsten fällt mir nichts ein
Ich habe sicherlich noch das ein oder andere Video disliked
Aber fällt mir jetzt nichts ein, gerade
Das Frontal 21 Video
Ne, das hat mich nicht großartig gejuckt
Auch wenn der Inhalt bescheuert ist
Tronax, drei Monate
Dankeschön für den Sub
Massive Subscriptions wieder her
So, was gucken wir jetzt?
Gucken wir uns als nächstes an
Warum habe ich meine eigenen Videos auf?
Jetzt hat jeder schon mal ein letztes
Cringe Video geguckt, oder?
Laut Gamestar soll Diablo Immortal
Gar nicht so schlecht sein
Das kann ich mir sogar vorstellen
Ich glaube auch gar nicht mal, dass
Diablo Immortal wirklich ein
Extrem schlechtes Mobile Game wird
Wahrscheinlich wird das sogar ganz gut
Aber das Timing
Und wo sie das präsentiert haben
Das war einfach so fail
Wo man gesehen hat, dass Blizzard mittlerweile
Total detached abgehoben
Von dem ist, was die Leute sich vorstellen
Ich meine, die können doch nicht
Auf ihrer Messe
Auf ihrer hauseigenen Veranstaltung
Wo die Leute quasi teilweise aus der ganzen Welt
Anreisen
PC, Blizzard, Fanboys
Da können die doch nicht
Nachdem fünf Jahre Funkstille war um Diablo
Diablo Immortal ankündigen
Und so tun, als wäre das jetzt das
Was die Leute sich gewünscht haben
Das mit den Programmiermemes war geil
Ja, ich dachte mir, dass das nicht so geil ist
Das hat ja auch nur 10.000 Views gekriegt
Aber ich fand es lustig
Hat auch Spaß gemacht aufzunehmen
Genau, Captain Peng
Das war das Problem
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass Diablo Immortal
Wie sieht es damit eigentlich gerade aus
Dass das wirklich schlecht wird
Aber das Timing war einfach schlecht
Oh, wir haben Diablo
Und wir hatten richtig
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
Boris am Start
So
An der Seite hat sich auch nichts
Der arme Typ
Der hat sich auch nichts gemacht
Der hat es ja echt abgekriegt
An der Seite hat sich nichts getan
Seit drei Jahren, oder?
Oh doch, tatsächlich
Ja, okay, es gab vier News
Es gab vier News seit zwei Jahren
Alles klar, GG
Der wurde richtig geflammt
Das ist der Typ, der auf der Bühne stand
Und gefragt hat, ob die Leute keine Telefone haben
Darum solltest du jetzt keinen PC kaufen
Okay, zeig mal her
Warum sollte ich jetzt keinen PC kaufen?
Und herzlich willkommen bei Hardware
Ey, also
Jetzt mal ernsthaft
Wer hat sich da das Intro voneinander abgeguckt?
Hat sich Hardware-Rad das von Hardware-Deals abgeguckt?
Oder Hardware-Deals das von Hardware-Rad?
Ich meine, hört euch mal dieses Intro an
Hey Leute und herzlich willkommen
Bei Hardware-Deals
Hört euch das mal an
Und dann hört euch das Intro mal an
Hallo
Hallo und willkommen bei Hardware-Rad
Ich finde das halt schülselig an
The fuck
Hey Leute und herzlich willkommen
Bei Hardware-Deals
Das
Hardware-Rad war der erste
Das kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen
Weil ich glaube nicht, dass er sich was abgucken würde
Zumindest kein Intro, oder?
Denn es geht um ein Thema, was jetzt schon seit einiger Zeit aktuell ist
Und über das wir unbedingt mal sprechen
Na dann, dann sprechen wir drüber
Na ja
Also
Es ist ja nicht so, als müsste man sich jetzt unbedingt
Einen neuen Rechner machen
Also
Einen neuen Rechner kaufen, ne?
Moin Twinko
Es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagen muss
Jetzt, jawoll
Also, wenn ich jetzt nicht mein Geld in neue Rechner investieren kann
Dann, dann
Keine Ahnung
Implodiere ich instant
Der Kram ist halt teuer
Das liegt unter anderem daran
Weil AMD was geiles rausgebracht hat
Nvidia, Nvidia auch
Allerdings Nvidia ist ja bekannt dafür, dass die Sachen teilweise nicht lieferbar sind
Dass AMD was geiles rausgebracht hat
Alle AMD wollen, aber es zu wenig gibt
Das ist ja so der Hauptsächliche Knackpunkt
Knackpunkt
So
Deswegen, ich wollte mir eigentlich auch einen neuen PC kaufen
Ende des Jahres
Aber warum
Warum soll ich ein Drittel mehr bezahlen
Oder sagen wir mal ein Viertel bis ein Drittel mehr bezahlen
Für einen Rechner
Jetzt, als wenn ich das nächstes Jahr mache
Ich meine, mein Rechner
Der ist ja nicht so, dass der schlecht ist
Von jetzt auf gleich
Ja, dazu kommt, dass du kaum noch
Grafikkarten kriegst
Also es sackt halt einfach, ne?
Und ich glaube das einzige, was man gerade
Bekommt ist RAM
Ich glaube Arbeitsspeicher bekommt man ganz gut
Mir geht es dabei nicht nur um die Verfügbarkeit
Von Grafikkarten und CPUs
Sondern inzwischen ist das Problem einfach viel größer geworden
Und die ganze PC-Szene
Shops und Hersteller und darum natürlich
Auch wir Verbraucher werden daran noch
Einige Zeit zu knabbern
Also mit BenQ und
Also mit BenQ hatte ich ja zumindest um 5 Ecken schon mal was zu tun
Aber mit Velux sagt mir gar nichts
Meiner Meinung nach ist die Situation aktuell
Sogar noch schlimmer als während der Mining-Krise
Als man kaum Grafikkarten bekommen hat
Weil die Leute einfach anfangen blind alles zu kaufen
Sogar alten Scheiß
Einfach nur um etwas zu kaufen
Und daran ist mit Sicherheit auch irgendwie die Weihnachtszeit schuld
Aber es macht alles nur noch schlimmer
Und darum sollten wir unbedingt mal miteinander reden
Und wie
Ist das, ist das, was ist das für ein Lüfter?
Ist das ein Noctua in schwarz?
Oder ist das was anderes?
Kann die Lüfter teilweise nicht mehr auseinander halten?
Wie schlimm die Gesamtsituation aktuell genau ist
Wie es in nächster Zeit weiter geht
Und warum ihr euch aktuell wirklich keinen PC bauen solltet
Und warum es nicht mehr so gut ist
Und warum es sich tatsächlich extrem lohnt noch ein bisschen zu warten
Das schauen wir uns in diesem Video an
Dieses Video wird euch präsentiert von der neuen Flaggschiff-Tastatur
Aus dem Hause Corsair
Der K-Album
Ah, yes
Alter
Diese Tastatur
Das ist jetzt gut
Es ist jetzt tatsächlich mal gut, dass dieser Sellout kommt
Ich hatte diese Tastatur
Beziehungsweise den direkten Vorgang K95
Das war die
Beschissenste Tastatur
Die ich jemals hatte
Obwohl ich es nicht mehr hatte
Obwohl die teuer as fuck ist
Ich weiß nicht was der Kram mittlerweile kostet
Guck mal hier
200 Euro für eine Tastatur
Und die war so scheiße
So
Und jetzt vielleicht nicht einfach nur um rum zu flamen
Und jetzt mal konkret zu sagen
Was da dran scheiße war
War ja wahrscheinlich nicht jeder dabei
Als ich mich da mehrere Streams hintereinander drüber ausgelassen hab
Also
Das erste was mir auf den Keks gegangen ist
Ist das Layout
Aber da kann man sich ja noch drüber streiten
Dass zum Beispiel
Wenn du beispielsweise oftmals das Gefühl hattest
Du drückst G6 anstatt Control
Über das Layout kann man sich dran gewöhnen
Kann man sich noch drüber streiten
Die Tasten waren rutschig
Also ich bin selten auf einer Tastatur
So rumgerutscht
Ähm
Wie auf diesen Tasten
Dazu kamen mir die Tasten relativ klein vor
Was aber nicht stimmt
Wahrscheinlich sind die Tasten exakt so groß wie alles andere
Aber das schlimmste und was die Tastatur wirklich komplett ins Ausreize befördert hat
Und warum ich sage das ist die Schleimhaut
Die schlimmste Tastatur
Die hat direkt am zweiten Tag oder so angefangen
Doppelte Tastaturanschläge zu fabrizieren
Das ging dann wieder weg
Und dann hat eine andere Taste angefangen
Also ganz ganz grausam
Und doppelte Tastaturanschläge
Da habe ich wirklich Anfälle bekommen
So und dann
Ich überlege gerade was der eigentliche Knackpunkt war
Warum ich sie ausgetauscht habe
Ich glaube weil irgendeine Taste nicht mehr ging
Ich habe die ja nach einem halben Jahr oder so ausgetauscht
Ähm vielleicht weiß
Chat wisst ihr das noch warum habe ich die ausgetauscht damals
Also es waren doppelte Tastaturanschläge von Anfang an
Ja doch doch genau
Ich weiß wieder warum ich die ausgetauscht habe
Weil oder zumindest einer einer der Teile davon
Weil V richtig rumgespackt hat mit doppelten Anschlägen
Ich habe teilweise copy pasted
Und dreimal pasted und sowas
Ne Control ist bei der Logitech Tastatur abgebrochen
Das war nicht die
Die Tasten hielten hier zumindest
Aber was ich wie gesagt was mir hier nicht ganz gefallen hat
Ist auch das man ziemlich rumgerutscht ist auf den Tasten
Aber doppelte Anschläge auf V
Das ist das was mich echt zur Weißglut gebracht hat
Ich habe was copy pasted
Und hatte es auf einmal 5 mal drin
Oder 3 mal drin oder so
Das war ganz ganz grausam
Ja ne
Also ganz ehrlich für diese
Für den Preis
Ist das gebotene wirklich Müll
Das kannst du nicht machen
Dazu kommt was man auch nicht vergessen hat
Ich weiß gar nicht ob ich auch noch drauf habe
Cortana
Die Corsair Software ist auch absoluter Crap
Wir haben ja mal im Stream versucht
45 Minuten ein Makro zu erstellen
Das ist echt abenteuerlich
Man kann ja über die Logitech Software sagen was man will
Ich meine das Ding ist Hardcore Oldschool
Aber wenigstens kannst du da drin gute Makros machen
So
Also grausame Tastatur
Ganz ganz ganz großer Müll
Achja was auch Müll ist
Die Unterlage für die Handballen
Die ist viel zu steil
Und die ist auch viel zu hart
Alles Sachen
Es ist alles Geschmackssache
Aber wo man halt nicht drüber
Diskutieren kann
Ist doppelte Tastenanschläge
Bei einer 200 Euro Tastatur
Auf mehreren Tasten unterschiedlich
Und gerade bei V für copy paste
Das darf nicht sein
Rest mag alles noch
Geschmackssache sein
Aber das kann es nicht sein
Exzellent
K100 RGB
Ich hätte noch Questions
Ja richtig
So sieht es aus
Gerade wenn man Stackoverflow copy pastet
Da geht das mal gar nicht
Also man muss ja eins sagen
Man muss ja eins sagen
Zu diesen
Alten PS2 Tastaturen
Ich würde damit nicht arbeiten wollen
Nicht spielen wollen
Mit so einem fetten IBM Keyboard
Die Dinger sind ja mittlerweile sehr beliebt
Aber die sind 50 Jahre später
Immer noch so stabil
Und so resistent
Dass du damit erstmal einen Einbrecher K.O. schlagen könntest
Und danach weiterspielen
Der Fäkalien Sammler hat abonniert
Massive Subscription
So
Ich muss dich warnen
In dem Chat hier gibt es nicht so viel zu sammeln
In der Richtung
Weil der Chat ist hier
Big Brain Chat
So
Wie gesagt
Doppelte Tastenanschläge
Bei einer 200€ Tastatur
Für 200€ wahrscheinlich
Könnte man sich ja fast was bauen lassen
Wisst ihr woran es liegen könnte
Das Kopiervorgänge immer auf 99% eine Weile stehen bleiben
Und generell
Ja
Windows hat einen Bug
Wenn du zu viele Icons
Also wenn du zu viele Dateien in einem Ordner hast
Und du hast diesen Ordner
Im Explorer offen
Oder
Warte mal
Ob es vielleicht
Oder ob es dieser
Datei speichern Dialog sein muss
Dann
Braucht er lange um neue Sachen zu erstellen
Siehst du es
Ich habe jetzt gesagt neuer Ordner
Achtung
Wo ist es
Der hat es jetzt gar nicht gecheckt gerade
Also da ist Windows ein bisschen verbuggt
Habt ihr es gesehen
Habt ihr gesehen wie lange das laggt
Jetzt ging es schnell
Und wenn man mal schaut wie viele Sachen du drinnen hast
Dann kann das schon ein bisschen länger dauern
Und ansonsten
Tja keine Ahnung
Es könnte ja auch sein
Das es erstmal in irgendeinem Cache landet
Und die Platte an sich extrem langsam schreibt
Es kann ja
Es kann an vielen Sachen liegen
Aber das mit vielen Dateien in einem Ordner
Und wenn man dann was neues erstellt
Ist mir schon öfters aufgefallen bei Windows
Und wenn ihr denkt mein Desktop hier sieht schlimm aus
Der Chat sagt ja immer mein Desktop sieht schlimm aus
Wobei ich ja sagen muss
Der sieht ja nur wegen dem Chat so schlimm aus
Guckt euch mal an was wir hier haben
Wir haben alle möglichen Emotes
Ist ja nicht so dass ich die nur
Für mein Enjoyment
Hier irgendwie auf dem Desktop habe
So zumindest
Wenn ihr denkt der Desktop ist schlimm
Übrigens es laggt auch wenn man die Icons markiert
Wie ihr seht
Ihr müsstet mal den Desktop sehen von meinem normalen
Der Chat ist immer Schuld
Natürlich
Ihr müsstet mal den Desktop sehen
Von meinem normalen User Account
Da dauert es teilweise 30 Sekunden
Bis ein Icon angelegt ist
Weil der so voll ist
Ich würde den nicht neu aufsetzen
Es bringt ja nichts
Du kriegst ja das Problem immer wieder
Du kannst die Ordner verschieben
Kannst die Ordner verschieben in einen Unterordner
Dann hast du das Problem nicht mehr
Oh die Insider hat es jetzt gefixt
Woran kann es liegen
Das Windows 10 ohne aktive Anwendung
Schon 3 GB RAM braucht
Weil Windows 10
Mäßig mittlerweile Sachen cached
Ist aber auch ok
Weil ganz im Ernst
Wenn man viel RAM hat
Was man nicht verwendet
Ist es verschenktes Geld
Also das ist nicht schlimm
Das heißt nicht zwangsläufig
Dass du zu wenig RAM hast für andere Anwendungen
Also eigentlich ist es sogar gut
Wenn ein Betriebssystem
Möglichst viel den
Äh das hier
Wenn du möglichst viel den RAM
Voll klatscht
Guck mal
Ich habe benutzt 10 GB
10 GB RAM
Äh von 32
10G
Überleg dir das mal
Für nichts
Ich habe nichts auf
Ein paar Youtube Tabs
Und Windows cached ein paar Sachen schon vor
Hat den Vorteil
Wenn du es dann startest ist es schnell
Eigentlich ist es tatsächlich eine ganz gute Sache
Ich habe OBS offen
Ja aber OBS
Memory Usage
Ist natürlich ganz wichtig
Wir haben Chrome
Also Chrome allein
Braucht ja hier schon mal 3G
Oder so
Aber der Rest das braucht nichts
Also wenn ihr euch das hier anguckt
Das sind nie im Leben 10G
Und Windows hat halt irgendwelche Sachen im Vorfeld schon gecached
Falls ich sie öffnen würde
Wohin soll ich gehen dahin
Darf ich das dahin
Ah hier
Okay Chrome braucht 5G
So das war es aber
Ne siehste
Also die weiteren 5G sind halt irgendwelche gecachten Sachen
Macht es heutzutage noch Sinn
Windows ab und zu neu aufzusetzen
Nö überhaupt nicht
Gar nicht
Ich setze Windows nie neu auf
Ich habe sogar beim vorletzten PC die SSD umgezogen
Aus dem alten in den neuen Rechner
Auf dem hier habe ich es jetzt mal neu installiert
Weil ich das auf NVMe SSD habe
Aber trotzdem ansonsten
Läuft Windows bei dir in der VM? Nö
Das ist auf dem Haus drauf
Beim Desktop
Ich habe Linux in der VM laufen
Aber auch aktuell gerade nicht an
Hier ne
Also da würde ich mir keine Gedanken machen
Wenn das RAM verbraucht
Das ist eigentlich sogar ganz gut
Okay Leute was gucken wir uns als nächstes an
Was haben wir da
Flirtbots auf Instagram
Ah ja ja
Sind Flirtbots auf Instagram
Ein bisschen was wie
Weibliche Charaktere in MMOs
Die nach Gold betteln
Das geht doch in die ähnliche
Das geht doch in die ähnliche Richtung
Oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht ob das heute noch so angesagt ist
Aber früher hattest du in MMOs
Immer welche im Startgebiet stehen
Die haben sich einen weiblichen Charakter erstellt
Und haben halt gesagt
Sie sind halt IRL
Grill
Und haben dann erzählt so nach dem Motto
Sie brauchen Gold
Eigentlich richtig billig gewesen
Und das haben auch genug Leute gemacht
Das haben auch
Das haben auch genug Leute gemacht
Weil sonst hätte sich das ja nicht durchgesetzt
Das hätten nicht immer mehr Leute versucht
Ich fand das lustig
Die haben dann teilweise auch richtig versucht
So Mädels in MMOs zu imitieren
Das waren halt definitiv alles keine Mädels
Die haben dann halt
Auch dieses
Girlie Chat
Gehabe versucht
In MMOs zu imitieren
Hihi und sowas in der Richtung
Also früher in MMOs
Haben die Mädels immer sowas geschrieben
Hihi
Diese Kombination Alter
Hihi Nasensmiley
Ich weiß nicht was heute angesagt ist
Heute machen die Mädels wahrscheinlich
Keine Smilies mehr
Heute machen die wahrscheinlich permanent irgendwelche Emojis
Oder sonst wie
Aber Hihi
Achja übrigens Leute
Die einzig richtige
MMO Lache ist tatsächlich
Muhahaha
Ja es war noch Zeiten wo man Chats verwendet hat
In MMOs
Heute verwendet man wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil
Emojis
Oder ich würde heute wahrscheinlich Twitch Emojis
Ingame verwenden
Wenn heute einer was lustiges
Mach ich ja im Ingame Chat bei allen anderen Sachen auch schon
Aber wenn einer was lustiges schreibt im Chat
Keck weh egal ob es die Plattform
Das Emoji gibt oder nicht
Okay also
Guck mal was da
Instagram Flirtbots zeig ich mal her
Man kennt das
Nee
What the fuck
Geh weg Windows
Das kenn ich nicht
Weil ich hab kein Instagram
Und werd prinzipiell auch dort nicht von alten Schulfreunden angeschrieben
Nicht aus Nostalgie sondern mit bestimmter Absicht tut
Und in den meisten Fällen haben wir damit auch Recht
Ich bin grad froh wenn mich keine alten Schulfreunde anschreiben
Wenn wir mit denen gar nichts mehr zu tun haben
Auf Instagram ist dieses Problem ähnlich
Nur das uns der Gesprächspartner nicht um Geld
Oder ein gutes Wort beim Arbeitgeber bittet
Sondern ein lukratives freizügiges Angebot macht
Aha
Das sich immer wieder neu zu unterbieten scheint
Finds ja auch witzig
Das sich die Flaume und die Aubergine
Als Emojis
Für ihr wisst schon durchgesetzt hat
Ja
Gibt es morgen ein Venice Unleashed Stream
Ja wenn das morgen wirklich raus kommt wirklich
Wie habt ihr euch kennengelernt
Naja sie hat damals unter mein Instagram Bild ungefragt
Ich denke meine Brüste sind zu groß
Pfirsich keine Flaume
Meinetwegen Pfirsich
Sieht doch fast genauso aus
Groß und verschwitzt
Kommentiert zu werden scheint sollte man
Ok
Also wenn jemand ungefragt
Unter einem Instagram Bild
Bei mir kommentieren würde
Ich denke meine Brüste sind zu groß
Und verschwitzt
Bin ich ein bisschen misstrauisch
Denkt man sich dann
Ach ja ach so
Ja also jetzt wo du es sagst
Kann ich mir das mal etwas näher angucken
Ja doch finde ich schon
Also die sind schon ein bisschen zu groß
Und verschwitzt
Also ganz mal ernsthaft
Wer kennt es nicht
Toponautin ist 4 Monate
Danke schön für den Sub
Vielleicht anfangen sich Gedanken um den Realismus in all dem zu machen
Aber soweit sind wir ja alle schon längst
Ganz kurz lästig und danach kein Thema mehr sind
Aber bei jedem Mal
Wenn mir das Fake Profil eines russischen Models
Erneut ihre Liebe gesteht
Und von mir selbiges erwartet
Komm ich in die Versuchung einzuwenden
Das ist wie
Das sind die neuen Spam E-Mails im Endeffekt
Den ganzen den gleichen Scheiß
Gab es schon vor 20 Jahren
Per Mail
Ich bin ein einsames
Polnisches Hausfrau
Hier kannst du meine
Hier kannst du meine Bilder sehen
Hier kann man einfach
Und solche eMails ganz am laufenden Band
Und keiner hat sich dafür interessiert
Und das ist mittlerweile auf Instagram
Das ist nichts neues
Instagram hat mittlerweile
Über 1 Milliarde Nutzer weltweit
Laut externen Untersuchung
Ist etwa jeder zehnte davon ein Bot
Das einfachste ist keinen Instagram zu haben
Dann hat man das Problem nicht
Die besagte Bot Art
Ist wesentlich häufiger vertreten
Als beispielsweise Bots die politische Einflussnahme zum Ziel haben
Klar, mit den Bots kannst du Geld verdienen, mit den anderen nicht.
... Bots fühlen sich besonders auf Instagram pudelwohl, denn die Plattform hat unfreiwillig ein Biotop für genau diese Masche kreiert.
Instagram will familienfreundlich sein.
Freizügigkeit wird nur zu einem gewissen Maß toleriert, jedoch dessen Gratwanderung vom Algorithmus immer wieder stark bevorzugt,
sodass das System allein durch seine Struktur dazu geführt hat, dass sich professionelle Influencer dazu gezwungen fühlen...
Ja, ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen, Belldelfin ist auch auf Instagram bekannt geworden.
... Sonnenuntergang irgendwie noch ihren Hintern oder ihr Sixpack unterzubringen.
Und die Frage ist natürlich, ist das Video sogar echt und nicht gefotoshoppt?
Ist das wirklich ein echtes Gras und ein echter Sonnenuntergang?
... Bild vom Sonnenuntergang irgendwie noch ihren Hintern oder ihr Sixpack unterzubringen.
Mittlerweile haben sich die Bots über Direktnachrichten, Gruppeneinladungen, Markierungen auf Fotos, Antworten auf Fragestickern,
Storys und Kommentare jede Form der Kontaktaufnahme auf Instagram erschlossen.
Selbst private Profile werden von den Bots über die Followerlisten anderer Nutzer gefunden.
Aber was ist denn nun genau deren Ziel?
Daten? Geld? Der Zugang zum eigenen Profil?
Vielleicht doch einfach...
Naja, wahrscheinlich eine Mischung aus Geld, Malware verteilen und Scam.
Scammas halt.
... Neigung? Nein.
Zunächst lässt sich das natürlich nicht pauschalisieren, weil hier mehrere Betrugsmaschen,
die von den gleichen Ködern fischen.
Es lässt sich aber die Beobachtung machen, dass eher die Unterzahl von ihnen an den eigenen Passwörtern oder anderen Daten interessiert sind,
sondern eher, wie so häufig, am eigenen Geldbeutel.
Ja, klar.
Bei erfolgreicher Kontaktaufnahme verlagert sich das Gespräch in die Instagram-Direktnachrichten,
wo, nach einigem Hin und Her, der Bot darauf aufmerksam macht, dass er doch viel lieber auf einer anderen Plattform schreiben möge,
Instagram sei irgendwie nicht so das wahre.
Um auch einen Anreiz für den Plattformwechsel zu bieten, ködert der Bot mit freizügigen exklusiven Fotos,
die viel zu krass für Instagram sind.
... Neigung? Nein.
Bei erfolgreicher Kontaktaufnahme verlagert sich das Gespräch in die Instagram-Direktnachrichten,
wo, nach einigem Hin und Her, der Bot darauf aufmerksam macht,
Instagram sei eine uralte Masche, aber sie findet immer noch ihre Opfer.
Ja, gibt ja auch genug Low-Brate-Leute, die auf sowas reinfallen.
... Neigung? Nein.
Wer fällt auf sowas rein?
Ganz ehrlich, mir ist es unerklärlich, aber das sind die gleichen Leute, die früher auf Viagra-Sperm reingefallen sind per Mail.
... Neigung? Nein.
Also, die gleichen Leute, so vom Gehirn her, bloß jetzt halt 30 Jahre jünger.
Aber es reicht ja auch, wenn einfach von, keine Ahnung, wenn du 10.000 Leute anschreibst,
das kostet dich ja im Endeffekt nix großartig,
und davon fallen, keine Ahnung, vielleicht ne Handvoll drauf rein, reicht schon.
... Seite mimt.
Der Name aus dem Instagram-Profil wird in die Maske übernommen und man wird auf eine komplett andere Seite weitergeleitet,
mehr dazu gleich.
Obwohl das spätere Profil auf der Dating-Seite weder Profilbild noch irgendein anderes Unterscheidungsmerkmal abseits des Namens aufweist,
ist das eigene Postfach direkt geflutet mit Fragen.
Es gibt Frauen, die sagen, man wäre ihnen unter allen anderen Profilen besonders aufgefallen.
Natürlich.
Vom ursprünglichen Instagram-Fake-Profil fehlt aber natürlich jede Spur.
Das Geschäftsmodell ist dann dementsprechend simpel.
Die ersten Nachrichten an die Interessierten sind kostenlos, danach muss man ca. 1 Euro pro Nachricht bezahlen.
Geile Entwicklung!
Geiler Chat!
Wer kennt's nicht?
Hallo, was machst du denn so?
Ich finde mich hier gerade zurecht.
Auf welchen Frauentyp stehst du denn so?
Zum Leben, ja.
Ach du Scheiße.
Gibt's hier eins noch?
Schon lange nichts mehr gehört.
Wobei, ich will auch gar nichts hören.
Wisst ihr, was der erste...
Muss ich jetzt echt noch mal kurz erzählen.
Wisst ihr, was der erste Channel war,
wo ich...
Katja Krasavitz...
Krasavitz, wie auch immer man die ausspricht.
Wo ich die zuerst gesehen hab, zum allerersten Mal.
Das war Ben Laxer.
Kennt jemand noch Ben Laxer?
Der, der...
Was weiß ich, der Mülltollen-Verschönerungsexperte
und sowas.
Ich fand das übelst lustig.
Den gibt's ja nicht mehr. Der hat irgendwie seinen Channel verkauft
oder sowas. Ben Laxer!
Kennt ihr noch jemanden?
Der Weltverschönerungsexperte.
Der Typ, der war richtig geil.
Ich weiß nicht, warum der seinen Channel verkauft hat.
Den gibt's ja nicht mehr.
Aber der war geil.
Sind ja auch nur Weiber da, ne? Ganz klar.
Und nachdem du dich angemeldet hast.
Alle, die warten nur drauf.
Ne, das macht irgendein Bot mittlerweile.
Und natürlich hat es auch psychische Konsequenzen,
wenn jemand merkt, dass die Person,
mit der man schon so lange schreibt,
ewig viel Geld für das Gespräch mit ihr ausgegeben hat
und in die man sich eventuell sogar verliebt hat,
gar nicht existiert.
Den gibt's nicht mehr, ne?
Nein, Ben Laxer, der hat seinen Channel...
Nein, nein, nein, der hat seinen Channel verkauft.
Vielleicht ist der mittlerweile wieder da.
Aber...
Der hat seinen Channel verkauft.
Ach, guck mal.
Und gibt's den echt wieder?
Nee.
Das ist irgendwas anderes.
Das ist überhaupt nichts von dem.
Das ist der doch gar nicht.
Das ist irgendwas anderes.
Der Typ hat seinen Channel verkauft.
Und...
Oder was auch immer.
Das hat mit dem gar nichts zu tun, ne?
Und das sind auch alte Videos,
die er neu hochgelaufen hat.
Hochgeladen hat, ja.
Warum verkauft man seinen YouTube-Kanal?
Wahrscheinlich, weil man es nötig hat.
Ups.
Oh, wir wollten uns ja eigentlich angucken,
warum man sich jetzt keinen PC kaufen soll.
Obwohl die Plattform mittlerweile den Einsatz
von Chatmoderatoren in ihren AGBs angeben.
Und die Antwort ist...
Vielleicht.
Denn man darf nicht einfach so irgendwelche Sachen
in die AGBs schreiben und wer sie nicht liest,
der hat dann Pech gehabt, sondern die darin enthaltenen
Informationen dürfen keine überraschende Wendung
mithalten.
Was bedeutet, einer Plattform,
die mit Partnern fürs echte Leben wirbt,
aber dann IKM-Schreiber nutzt,
könnte vor Gericht eine solche überraschende Wendung
nachgesagt werden.
Anzeige ist raus.
Welche Tastatur empfiehlst du für die Arbeit?
Also ich finde die Ducky One Skyline ziemlich gut.
Mit Numblock.
Die hier.
Oder mittlerweile vielleicht die Ducky One 2.
Kann auch sein.
Ich hab die alte noch mit Numblock.
Mit Numblock.
Wo ist der Numblock?
Ich will den mit Numblock.
Nicht Numlock.
Block.
Genau.
Die da.
Beste.
Richtig gut.
Habe ich auch schon eine Weile auf der Arbeit.
Was ich gemacht habe, ich habe noch so kleine Silikonringe
unter manche Tasten, wo ich besonders heftig
immer drauf haue, dass ich meine Mitarbeiter
auf der Arbeit nicht so sehr nerve.
Und wenn ich sie noch mal proben gelesen habe,
dann haue ich beispielsweise ganz gerne mal auf den
Numblock, auf das Numblock Enter und sowas.
Da habe ich beispielsweise, also ich habe
einen Ring unter dem Numblock Enter.
Ich glaube unter Control und normalem
Enter und Backspace oder irgendwie sowas.
Welche Switches? Boah, das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Kann ich dir nicht mal sagen, was ich die gekauft habe.
Das, was damals Default Standard drin war.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich kenne mich damit auch nicht wirklich gut.
Mit mechanischen Tastaturen.
Ich kann euch da nicht viel raten.
Ich hatte ein paar, alle waren scheiße,
bis auf die Ducky One Skyline und die aktuelle Logitech,
die ihr habt, geht auch halbwegs.
Nein.
Das ist ein bisschen wie ein
Spaziergang auf Instagram.
Hier findet sich erneut ein Affiliate-Netzwerk,
ähnlich wie beim Scam auf Facebook wieder.
Die Plattform beschäftigen Drahtzieher von Bot-Armeen,
die die Link-Platzierung an die höchstbietende
Plattform verkaufen.
Nach dem UWG, dem Gesetz gegen unlauteren
Wettbewerb, ist allerdings diese Art der
direkten Kontaktaufnahme zur Kundenakquise
hierzulande illegal.
Ja gut, ja, dann verfolgt das mal auf Instagram.
Good luck.
Telefonanrufe und analoge wie digitale Post
dürfen in diesem Fall nur nach ausdrücklicher
Nachricht.
Das ist doch dem China-Bot egal.
Das ist ja überhaupt nichts Neues, dieser Scam.
Der Scam ist...
Ja.
Ich wollte schon erzählen, dass mein Vater
früher was ähnliches gemacht hat.
Leute gescampt auf ähnliche, äh,
Art und Weise.
Also, das ist nicht neu und das hat er 1980 gemacht.
Und wisst ihr, was das Beste ist?
Das wurde ja sogar damals,
also, wie gesagt, mein Vater hat so eine
Partnervermittlung gehabt damals.
Ich hab's schon letztens im Stream erzählt, aber nur mal ganz kurz.
Mein Vater hat damals auch so eine Partnervermittlung gehabt,
wo es halt echt nicht drum ging, die Leute halt
einen Partner zu vermitteln, sondern halt
die Leute möglichst lange bezahlen zu lassen.
Und der hat die halt
übelst gebadet und übelst verarscht, ja.
Aber das Ganze wurde sogar
später vor einem Gericht
verhandelt und da wurde
freigesprochen.
Und der Richter muss damals wohl noch irgendeine
Person gefragt haben, also,
die haben sich den Vertrag angeguckt, den die Leute
so unterschrieben haben, und der Richter
muss damals wirklich jemand noch gefragt haben,
ja, warum haben sie das so, oder warum haben sie
sowas denn überhaupt unterschrieben?
Also, sprich, der Vertrag muss schon
extrem einseitig
gewesen sein, ja.
Und, ähm,
also man sieht, wenn mein Vater
auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise Leute
1900, frag mich nicht,
85 bis 1990 rum
gescampt hat, das ist
nix Neues. Und,
ähm,
das wird's immer geben.
Das wird's immer geben. Plus
halt in anderer Art und Weise, ja.
Chatbots auf Instagram.
Tja, gut, ich hab kein Instagram-Account,
mir fallen da auch keine
Chatbots auf. Wir wollten übrigens das Video
angucken, warum man sich grad kein PC
kaufen soll, fällt mir auf. Schaut dein Vater
aus wie ein russisches Model? Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Der hat das anders gemacht.
Der hat Partnervermittlung
nicht für Männer gemacht, sondern nur für Frauen.
Und der hatte
Männer, die halt im passenden
Alter sind, gut ausgeschaut
haben und halt im Prinzip
den älteren Damen mehr oder weniger
alles erzählt haben, was die hören wollten.
Und, ähm, die Mädels fanden das
halt dann ganz toll und haben halt gedacht, oh ja,
das ist der, wie hat der Asitoni gesagt,
das ist der Mann fürs Leben.
Und haben halt munter weiter
Beiträge bezahlt.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, ein paar fanden's
sogar richtig gut.
Also, tja.
Wie gesagt,
die Masche ist nicht neu.
Es ist nix Neues bei,
ja? Genau, also, warum
sollen wir uns keinen neuen PC
kaufen?
Ich überspring mal kurz
die Werbung, weil ich hab mich ja schon
zu dieser Tastatur ausgelassen, dass ich den Vorgang
grausam schlecht fand.
Findet ihr in der Videobeschreibung.
Die Idee zu diesem Video ist aus
genau zwei Gründen entstanden.
Erstens, weil sich in letzter Zeit ne bestimmte
Art Kommentar auf diesem Kanal und auch
meinem Instagram- und Twitter-Account häuft,
und zwar die Art, die man eigentlich nicht lesen möchte.
Ich und auch meine anderen
YouTube-Kollegen werden nämlich teilweise extrem
angefeindet. Das ist normal.
Immer. Du kannst auf YouTube nichts
machen, wo nicht irgendwie Leute sich angegriffen
fühlen. Sogar beleidigt, weil die Leute
sauer sind, dass sie die PCs und Komponenten,
die wir empfehlen, nicht kaufen können.
Und zweitens... Ey, Kurzwort!
Nix gegen E-Girl GG, ja?
... Homepage und die ganzen PC-Konfigurationen
dort immer aktuell zu halten.
Oh, E-Pal ist es ja mittlerweile.
Aktuell ist es aber einfach nicht möglich.
Ich mein, ich würd gerne ne 3080
bei meinem 1500 und ne 3070
bei meinem 1000-Euro-PC empfehlen.
Also ich bin eher für ne
3090 bei dem 1000-Euro-PC.
Weil dann bekommt man
wenigstens ne Grafikkarte für das Geld.
Auch die neuen 305000er-CPUs, was,
wenn man die UVPs anschaut, absolut
realistisch wär. Aber was bringt es mir, euch
irgendwelche Komponenten zu empfehlen,
die man überhaupt nicht kaufen kann aktuell,
und wenn, dann halt nur zu absolut kranken
Wucherpreisen. Ich mein, im Kern
macht man das Problem damit ja nur noch schlimmer.
Denn man erhöht die Nachfrage für ein Produkt,
was man aktuell nicht oder nur in
winzigen Mengen kaufen kann, und dadurch
natürlich auch irgendwie den Preis. Also
Angebot und Nachfrage eben.
Schauen wir uns mal kurz den aktuellen Markt an.
In letzter Zeit sind einige echt coole neue Komponenten
vorgestellt worden. Die RTX 3080
zum Beispiel, ne Grafikkarte, die ich
selbst reviewed hab, und die vor allem
für ihre geile Preis-Leistung gefeiert wurde.
Und warum sollte ich mir jetzt keinen Rechner
kaufen? Jetzt kommen wir zum Punkt.
Ich wusste zu dem Zeitpunkt halt nicht, dass man die Karte
in absehbarer Zeit nicht für die UVP
bekommen wird. Schlimmer noch, wenn
wir mal bei Geizhals nach ner RTX 3080
schauen, die UVP ist übrigens
699 Euro. Ja, das ist,
wenn der Scheiß neu ist, immer so. Und das geht mir auch
auf den Sack, dass mittlerweile die meisten
Launches so laufen.
Es kommt irgendwas Neues raus,
der Hersteller sagt irgendeinen Preis, es gibt
dann so wenig davon, dass man teilweise
monatelang gar nichts kriegt, und wenn man was
nicht kriegt, kostet es ein Drittel mehr.
Gut, wer
das macht, der ist ja wirklich hängengeblieben.
Aber der günstigste Preis...
Wisst ihr, was Big Brain wäre?
Wenn ich Hardware-Shop wäre, dann würde ich
3090 anbieten fürs Doppelte,
und dann, wenn einer es bei mir
kauft, kaufe ich es bei Ebay
und schicke es an den Typen weiter.
... sind halt 699 Euro,
und das, obwohl die Karte eine UVP
von 499 hat.
Bei der 3060 Ti sah es kurz nach dem
Launch echt gut aus, aber auch da
inzwischen der günstigste Anbieter, Computer
Universe, mit 569 Euro... Leerverkäufe,
quasi, quasi sowas in der Richtung.
... mit einer UVP von
399 Euro.
Und bei dem Händler bin ich mir auch tatsächlich unsicher,
ob die Ware auch wirklich auf Lager ist.
Ich habe da mal selbst Zubehör für unsere
Studiolampe bestellt, und zwar
bei dem Shop, weil sie die kürzeste Lieferzeit
hatten. Naja, bestellt hatte ich im März,
und das Lieferdatum war ursprünglich der 2. April.
Ab dem 2. April habe ich
dann wöchentlich E-Mails bekommen, dass die Ware
nächste Woche kommt, und
angekommen ist sie dann viele Monate später,
und zwar am 28. September.
Und genau so werden viele Shops aktuell
vorgehen, um Vorbestellungen zu sammeln.
Und zwar, indem sie relativ kurze Lieferzeiten
vorgaukeln, und die dann halt Woche
für Woche immer wieder nach hinten schieben.
Man muss also wirklich aufpassen, aktuell.
Von den AMD 5000er CPUs
müssen wir eigentlich auch gar nicht erst anfangen.
Nur kurz ein Blick auf den Ryzen 7 5860...
Ja, ey, das ist nicht normal, wenn du dir sowas
heute kaufen willst. Es gibt welche, ne?
Also wenn ich mit 5... Also ich wollte mit 5900X
kaufen. Das kostet
5900X...
So.
Guckt euch mal die Preise an. Ah, okay.
Okay, okay, ja.
Also normalerweise sollte das
599 kosten. Das kostet 57.
Also das kostet einfach mal 200 Euro
mehr.
Der Preis schwankt zwischen 440, was
sehr nah an der UVP ist, und knapp
700 Euro. Das große Problem
ist aber, dass die Leute das tatsächlich
für diese Preise kaufen, und damit...
Ja, das ist echt das Problem. Ganz ehrlich,
dann würde ich mit... Wenn ich mir jetzt
was kaufen würde, dann würde ich mir tatsächlich
lieber nochmal ein Intel-System
kaufen, weil es preis-leistungsmäßig
einfach attraktiver ist.
Es ist doch bescheuert, zu sagen,
okay, AMD hat eigentlich die bessere
Hardware und das bessere System, und normalerweise
ist es preis-leistungsmäßig auch wirklich
angemessen, aber dann 200 Euro
mehr für auszugeben, ergibt ja gar keinen Sinn.
...den Preis halt immer weiter
nach oben schießen lassen. Inzwischen sind selbst
in Anführungszeichen alte Komponenten,
wie der Ryzen 5 2600 und
3600... Ja, das ist total hängen geblieben.
Ich meine, der 2600er ist innerhalb
eines Monats von 112,50 Euro...
Ja, also das ist hängen geblieben, das ist irgendwie
vier Jahre, fünf Jahre alte CPU oder so...
Ne, ja, nicht ganz. Vier, vier, drei, drei, drei bis
vier Jahre, aber das ist...
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
wer so bescheuert ist. Schauen wir uns mal ein Mittelklasse-Modell
wie die RX 5700 XT
von AMD an. Die günstigste Karte
kostet 475 Euro,
ist also innerhalb der letzten zwei Wochen
um sage und schreibe 20%
gestiegen. Richtig hängen geblieben. Schlimmer gemacht ist auch dadurch,
dass es bei den Nvidia-Karten die
Vorgängermodelle quasi gar nicht mehr gibt.
Die günstigste 2080 Super
kostet zum Beispiel einfach mal 900 Euro
und wie gesagt, das ist halt so, weil
die Leute den Scheiß immer noch kaufen
und zwar auch zu solchen überteuerten Preisen.
Ja, das stimmt. Und das zieht sich wirklich durch alle Bereiche.
Bei RAM ist es jetzt dadurch, dass
bei Micron ein Stromausfall war...
Stimmt. Ich hab's nur am Rande mitbekommen.
... war noch schlimmer
geworden. Das sieht man schön am Preis vom
G.Skill Aegis Kit. Das ist einfach innerhalb der
letzten drei Monate von 46
auf knapp 60 Euro gestiegen. Ja.
Also über 30%... Aber RAM ist, aber
RAM, muss man ehrlich sagen, RAM
ist im Vergleich von vor
äh, keine Ahnung, zwei, drei Jahren
ist es immer noch zaumäßig billig.
... geworden. Das führt dazu, dass
zum Beispiel selbst mein 700-Euro-PC,
also eine Konfiguration, die von den neuen
RTX 3000 und Ryzen 5000er
Releases eigentlich gar nicht betroffen ist,
inzwischen knapp 900 Euro
kostet. Der PC ist innerhalb von zwei
Wochen um 200 Euro gestiegen.
Und jetzt stehen wir eben vor dem
Weihnachtsgeschäft, was dafür sorgt, dass die Nachfrage... Einfach kein PC kaufen. Easy.
... noch weiter nach oben steigt. Und es gibt
natürlich mit Cyberpunk 2077
ein Spiel, was auch viele dazu bewegen wird,
aufzurüsten. Ah, ah, da habe ich
so meine Zweifel, ob die Leute jetzt noch wegen
Cyberpunk aufrüsten. Vielleicht sogar einen komplett
neuen PC zu holen. Und
ich kann an der Stelle nur eins sagen. Kauft
euch aktuell keinen PC, lasst
es einfach, denn es gibt eigentlich nur zwei
Szenarien, die eintreten können. Das ist auch so ein Wettbewerb.
Wer kann mehr RGB-Lüfter einbauen
in seinen Rechner?
Erstens, ihr bekommt zwar
einen PC, aber zahlt viel zu viel dafür,
und glaubt mir, in ein paar Monaten werdet
ihr euch darüber ärgern... Wie macht man eigentlich so
coole Kamerafahrten?
... kein PC, lasst es einfach... Das muss man doch auf
irgendeiner Schiene machen, oder? ... wenn es gibt eigentlich nur zwei Szenarien, die
eintreten können. Oder wie macht man sowas?
Erstens, ihr bekommt zwar einen PC, aber zahlt viel zu
viel dafür, und glaubt mir, in ein paar Monaten
werdet ihr euch darüber ärgern, wenn ihr 2000
Euro für einen PC gezahlt habt, der dann nur
noch die Hälfte kostet. Oder zweitens,
ihr bekommt den PC zwar, den ihr bestellt habt,
aber halt viel... Der Tisch dreht sich.
... auf keinen Fall mehr vor Weihnachten. Das wird's sein.
Denn auch das ist ein Punkt, an dem extra...
By the way, das sind diese Lüfter, wo irgendwie einer
30 Euro kostet, oder? Das sind doch diese
Corsa RGB, frag mich nicht, sonst was,
wo irgendwie ein Lüfter 30 Euro oder sowas kostet,
was auch fragwürdig ist. ... betrieben wird
und viele Shops die Blauäugigkeit der Nutzer
ausnutzen. Ich mein, ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher, dass 99% der Leute,
die jetzt bestellen, ihre Geräte noch
vor Weihnachten bekommen wollen.
Bei Agando zum Beispiel ist ein PC
Bestseller Nummer 1, der gleich zwei der heiß
begehrten Komponenten an Bord hat.
Ein Ryzen 5 5600X und
eine RTX 3070 für
649 Euro. Was zwar
viel zu teuer ist, aber lassen wir den Preis mal
beiseite, er ist der aktuelle Bestseller.
Auf der Produktseite selbst sucht man aber
vergeblich nach einem Hinweis, was die Lieferzeit
angeht. Erst wenn ich rechts in der Konfigurationsseite
nach unten scroll, dann gibt es einen dezenten
Hinweis darauf, dass es sich nur um Vorbestellungen
handelt, mit unbestimmtem
Liefertermin. Im Warenkorb dasselbe Spielchen.
Und ich will jetzt gar nicht diesen
speziellen Shop dafür an den Pranger stellen,
Agando hat sich in der letzten Zeit wirklich gebessert,
denn genau so gehen aktuell 90%
der Shops vor. Auf Teufel komm raus,
überteuerte Vorbestellungen sammeln,
die wahrscheinlich erst in Monaten bedient werden können.
Was ziemlich sagt. Und sowas solltet ihr als Verbraucher
auf keinen Fall unterstützen, denn
erstens wisst ihr nicht, wann ihr eure Produkte erhaltet.
Mal ganz im Ernst,
wenn irgendwo ein Shop drinnen stehen hat,
es ist ja auch schwierig zu erkennen,
Produkt XY lieferbar
in zwei bis drei Werktagen
und das ist in zwei bis drei
Werktagen noch nicht losgeschickt
und
die stellen sich irgendwie quer mit Geld
zurück, da mache ich direkt mal PayPal
Käuferschutzgedöns auf. Deswegen
mache ich das auch nur über Amazon Pay oder PayPal.
Ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock mehr, mich mit
irgendwelchen freidrehenden
Shop-Anbietern auseinanderzusetzen.
... halt ihr gerade einfach utopische Preise
dafür. Ich meine, wieso zur Hölle sollte
man etwas vorbestellen, das kein Liefertermin hat?
Es ist gut möglich,
dass es Anfang des Jahres einige große
Schwünge der neuen Komponenten gibt und dann
fallen die Preise halt wieder Richtung UVP.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass dann irgendjemand
der Idiot sein möchte, der sich ein paar Wochen
vorher alte Hardware zu überteuerten Preisen
gekauft hat, einfach nur um überhaupt
einen PC zusammenstellen zu können.
Manchmal heißt es eben einfach Geduld haben
und genau das sollte jetzt das oberste
Gebot sein. Ja, das stimmt. Ich weiß, es ist wirklich
schwierig und viele wollen halt... Wie gesagt,
mir juckt es auch schon seit über einem Jahr
in den Finger, einen neuen Rechner zu kaufen, aber es gab
halt noch keine gute Gelegenheit. Und
ich sehe es auch nicht ein, wenn ich mir eh schon
einen Rechner baue, der normalerweise um
die, was weiß ich, 4k oder so
kosten wird ungefähr, so über den Daumen gepeilt,
dann sehe ich nicht einen, der jetzt 5k da
dafür auszugeben, einfach um ihn jetzt zu haben.
Das ist mir so hängen geblieben.
Ich bin da in Bescheid, warum soll ich das machen?
Und es gibt auch Alternativen. Wenn es wirklich
um ein Weihnachtsgeschenk geht, dann verschenkt
zum Beispiel einfach Gutscheine für PC-Shops,
dann kann der Beschenkte sich einen PC gönnen, wenn
sich die Preise wieder normalisiert haben.
Und wenn ihr unbedingt Cyberpunk 2077
oder ein bestimmtes anderes Game
spielen wollt und aktuell keinen PC
oder vielleicht eine alte Krücke habt, gönnt euch
das Spiel einfach auf Google Stadia, GeForce Now
oder einem anderen Game Stream.
Habe ich gerade zum ersten Mal
wirklich eine Empfehlung für Google Stadia gehört?
Hat er gerade wirklich gesagt
Google Stadia?
Das habe ich jetzt richtig gehört.
Streamingdienst wie Shadow.
Damit könnt ihr die Wartezeit gut und
vor allem günstig überprüfen.
Stadia, genau.
Jedenfalls hoffe ich,
dass ich euch mit diesem Video ein bisschen zum Nachdenken
bringen konnte, denn auch wir verbrauchen
in der nächsten Woche ein neues Video.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
.
. . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . . .
Das ist doch kein 3D-gedrucktes Weihnachtsgeschenk, Alter.
Okay, okay, wenn du Kinder hast vielleicht, ja.
Was ist das denn?
Okay, wer freut sich nicht darüber,
einen 3D-gedruckten Coronavirus zu Weihnachten zu bekommen?
Warum?
Erst mal draufhusten.
Das ist doch kein 3D-Gedrucktes Weihnachtsgeschenk, Alter.
Du kannst das nicht sogar so literal machen.
Side note, ich habe diesen kleinen Jungen aus dem allerbisarren Filament, den ich je gesehen habe, geprintet.
Das ist purple PETG, nicht PLA.
Und es gläubt grün in der Dunkelheit.
Außerdem ist es voller Glitter.
Schwierig.
Dieses printable Virus macht einen entsprechenden Ornament.
Oder sogar einen milden Sardonic-Tree-Topper.
Aber es sind die Remixes, die das wirklich in epidemische Proportionen senden.
Hier ist ein Rona für deinen Extruder.
Hier ist ein Rona, der deine Masken hält.
Hier ist ein Rona, um dein Corona zu öffnen.
Einige Amerikaner können den Rona fürchten,
aber sie ändern ihren Ton, wenn sie den Buffer sehen.
Oh, was ein Stumpfsinn.
Nummer 8, Lift Pod.
Fotografer und Videografer sind die schlechtesten Menschen, um Gifts zu kaufen.
Weil alles...
Okay, nee, das brauche ich nicht.
Next.
Vielleicht machst du Office-Secret-Santa, und du hast Gary,
der nie mit jemandem spricht,
keine sozialen Medien hat
und nur plain Uniqlo-T-Shirts trägt.
Wer weiß, was Gary will?
Was ist in deinem Kopf, Gary?
Wenn du nicht weißt, was sie wollen,
gib ihnen etwas,
was niemand, absolut niemand, für sie gefragt hat.
Einladen Sie ein Crossbow, das Peanutbutter-Cups schießt.
Äh...
Es beginnt...
Was?
Okay, Peanutbutter-Cookies oder sowas,
das ist ja so eine typische Kokona-Geschichte.
Ich glaube, sowas gibt es hier gar nicht.
... mit einer Mädchen namens Kelly,
die eine Nacht schlief und träumte von einer mächtigen Waffe,
die...
Okay, das braucht man auch schon mal nicht.
Puzzle brauchen wir auch nicht.
Giftcard braucht man auch nicht.
Ein cute...
Ein cute Dumpster.
Eine niedliche Mülltonne.
Excellent.
This lovable dumpster, baby,
is the perfect symbol of the year.
If only because my printer...
Cute Dumpster.
This guy dealt with layer shifts,
ugly blobs and all kinds of disruptions,
but he's still smiling
because the surprisingly supportive Voidstarlab community
is watching.
Just attach his little dumpster doors
to his adorable dumpster body
and hand him off to the best...
Und warum sollte ich...
Also, was?
Warum?
Warum einen cute, cute Dumpster?
... special someone who had a real trash 2020.
Naja, okay.
... but they tuck inside him stays between the dumpster,
the recipient and the fire department.
Number three, lithophanes.
Nee, brauchen wir nicht.
Brauchen wir auch nicht.
What the hell, was ist das?
... and that's a one.
Say hello to number one, the cyclone,
the triple lift, triple tracker,
marble machine.
Weighing in at 250 grams...
Das braucht doch auch absolut keine Sau.
... and taking 18 hours or longer to print.
This group of loops, shoots and circuitous roots
is an absolute hoot.
Three intertwined marble raceways
dance and weave through a Rube Goldbergian masterpiece
and a built-in hand-cranked Archimedean screw
carries the balls back up to run again.
It's a gorgeous, intricate model
that exemplifies the creative potential of 3D printing.
It's hard to believe that this didn't need
any more time.
It's hard to believe that this didn't need any more time.
Any supports or glue.
What?
This model prints beautifully
with absolutely zero support or extra materials at all.
I even use PETG,
which is a lot...
Also so ein Ding auszudrucken in der Größe,
da braucht mein 3D-Drucker wahrscheinlich 30 Stunden für.
... PLA.
And apart from dropping that screw into place
and cleaning out the tunnels,
what you see here is exactly what came off my printer.
Even the marbles can be 3D printed,
although in my opinion...
Ja, ist echt so.
Ist echt so.
Du benutzt das einmal
und danach steht's rum.
Er hat gesagt, die Piss-Five?
Nice.
Alter, richtig sinnlos.
Richtig sinnlos, Alter.
Ah, Kekona-Musik, exzellent.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich es offen hatte, aber...
So, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
How much does multiplayer population matter?
Ey, komm doch auf das Game an.
So, das gucken wir uns nicht an.
Komm, wir gucken uns das neue Alpha-4-Games-Video an.
Was heißt neu?
Vom 1. Dezember, das ist schon 19 Tage alt.
Ich hab's aber noch nicht gesehen.
Alpha-4-Games-Video.
Alpha-4-Games-Beste.
Was haben wir denn ansonsten?
My Favorite Desktop.
Oh ne, das ist wieder was, wo ich mich drüber aufregen muss, weil es unsinniger Crap ist.
Danach gucken wir uns noch ein paar Battlefield-4-Trickshots an.
Excellent.
Warum hat es 368.000 Aufrufe?
Warte.
Und gute Bewertung.
People forehead.
Bible Trump.
Okay, gucken wir uns.
Alpha-4-Games.
Was hat er für ein neues Video?
Der bisherige Erfolg von Amazon-Games.
Oh, der bisherige Erfolg von Amazon-Games ist relativ einfach zusammenfassbar.
Paar Games released.
Zum größten Teil alles Crap.
Ähm, Sachen wieder eingestellt.
Kennt ihr noch diesen, diesen, ähm,
Overwatch-Moba-Verschnitt, den sie da hatten?
Dieses, ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie es heißt.
Crucible hieß es, genau.
Crucible Amazon.
Was sie wieder eingestellt haben.
Wo sie rausgebracht haben, festgestellt hat, die Leute finden es scheiße.
Danach gesagt haben, ah, wir machen das neue Beta.
Und dann wieder, ach guck mal, das gibt es doch nicht mal mehr auf der Seite.
Und dann wieder eingestellt.
Hahaha.
Die haben es richtig verschissen, äh.
Was, Moment, Moment, da muss ich jetzt mal.
Crucible Reddit.
Wir gucken mal, ob es, ob es da noch Leute.
Crucible, Play Crucible, okay.
Gibt es da irgendwas?
Hat das jemand interessiert?
3,2 Tausend, das ist ja nichts.
Das hat ja wirklich absolut niemand interessiert.
Crucible 2, 0.
Ganz bestimmt.
Kann man sich die Ergebnisse angucken.
Crucible, man sieht, man sieht ja daran mal wieder, auch die größten Kack-Fail-Games haben eine gewisse Fanbase.
Moment, was?
Man kann für Game of the Year voten?
Warum?
What the fuck?
Okay, war so, immer.
Äh, gucken wir uns mal das, gucken wir uns mal das Video an.
Amazon ist nun schon seit einer ganzen Weile im Videospielbereich tätig.
Sie haben ihren eigenen App Store.
Oh, Pilotwings.
Music.
Exzellent.
Aber wenn jeder einen Guide schreibt, wie man ihn umgehen kann.
Mit so wunderbaren eigenen Spielen wie.
Airport Mania.
Ja, das waren, das waren die ersten paar Dinger, die sie da entwickelt haben.
Die, die haben, äh, also die ersten paar Sachen, die sie gemacht haben, waren halt App Store Dinger.
Okay, daran, daran kann man jetzt das hier nicht unbedingt messen.
2.
Aber mal davon abgesehen, die Spiele, die danach kamen, waren auch kacke.
Air Patriots.
Simples.
Soooo.
Frag mir, ob sie auf dem Flugzeug gehen.
Sie haben mit der Lumbar Yard Engine ihre eigene Video-
Ja, äh, das ist, ist, ist, ist Lumbar Yard nicht das, wo sie Crytek, die CryEngine-Sachen lizenziert haben?
Spiel-Engine, die auf der CryEngine basiert, die-
Das Video ist eigentlich laut genug, oder? Soll ich den Tick lauter machen, oder?
Passt da eigentlich?
Genauso wie die CryEngine, die man freiwillig nutzen will.
Ja, aber Lumbar Yard ist ja CryEngine, ne?
Oder zumindest jemand, der jemals fertig wird.
Und nun seit einigen Jahren sind sie ebenfalls-
Hehehe, das stimmt.
Und nun seit einigen Jahren sind sie ebenfalls fertig.
Und nun seit einigen Jahren sind sie ebenfalls ganz vorne mit dabei, ihre eigenen Spiele zu verkaufen.
Beziehungsweise eher zu veröffentlichen, weil Verkaufen ist dann auch mal was anderes.
Und wieso auch nicht?
Amazon ist mit eine der größten Firmen der Welt.
Jeff Bezos ist der reichste Mann der Welt.
Am reichsten an-
Tim klingt ja äußerst motiviert bei dem Video, muss ich sagen.
... seiner Angestellten.
Die Infrastruktur ist also da.
Die Ressourcen erst recht.
Der Ausflug.
Der Ausflug in die feucht-fröhliche Welt der Daddeleien, Joysticks und unbezahlten Überstunden ist dann nur der nächste natürliche Schritt.
Wenn irgendjemand da draußen den großen Publishern zeigen kann, wie man es richtig macht, dann ja-
Dann definitiv nicht Amazon.
... wohl Amaz-
... amaz-
Ja, die coolen Leute würden ja natürlich auch Amazon sagen.
Crucible ist ein Multiplayer-
Oh nein, hör mal auf. Crucible.
... Crucible ist ein Multiplayer-
2017 schon längst vorbei ist im spiel kann man rum hüpfen und eine niedrige kamera haben
man kann auch gegner schlagen oder auf gegner schießen das ist animal crossing
wo sie die halbe todesanimation überhaupt abgespielt wurde manchmal hält man ich
muss ehrlich sagen ich habe es nicht ausprobiert ich habe es mir nur ein paar
mal aber ein paar mal auf twitch angeguckt und crucible hat mich so hat
mich in sind so extrem abgeschreckt dieses game das also dass das in die
hose geht das hätten wir hätten die eigentlich selbst erkennen müssen
das sieht richtig peinz champ auszuspielen aufgenommen hat muss die
ganze zeit nachgucken wie die steuerung noch mal geht wir sehen nach irgendwie
zwei minuten oder so vorgespult habe um zu sehen ob man noch etwas anderes macht
als um dasselbe ding sieht nicht so aus
also anscheinend habe ich mal gehört habe ich in seinem kommentar gelesen soll
das gameplay das video hast du schon mal geschaut nee nicht schon mal geschaut so
aussehen wie das von paragon nur schlechter paragon ja das da hätte ich
tatsächlich da wäre ich gespannt drauf gewesen was bei paragon rauskommt paragon
ist das was epic games entwickelt hat bevor ford das riesen ding geworden ist
was blöd ist weil paragon schon vor ein paar jahren
abgeschaltet wurde ja das stimmt schaffst du mal schlechter zu sein als etwas das
gar nicht mehr existiert und so hockte man sich hin hörte auf das feedback der
fans und passte bei amazon sein spiel noch ein wenig mehr an seine vorlage an
ich weiß noch als mein netzwerkchef damals extra meinte ich soll mich
gefälligst beeilen ein video zu machen bevor crucible down ist ich habe mich
nicht beeilt ein video zu machen bevor crucible down ist ende mai kam es raus
nach sorgfältiger marktforschung also dem gucken nach den spieler zahlen merkte
man dass es keiner spielte aber hatred dann in vitro vom zurück in die close
beta und hat man es eingestellt spielte um jetzt endgültig abgeschaltet zu
werden da keiner spielte herzlichen glück es
dauerte nicht mal ein jahr und jetzt spielt es nicht wirklich genau so wie
paragones dazu gibt es in game grand tour das spiel dazu gibt es eine kleine
Ist das ein Game? Wer braucht denn dazu
ein Game?
Ich schaue die Serie
auch nicht regelmäßig. Ich gucke mal ab und zu
mal in eine Folge rein, weil ich es zwischendurch
mal ganz lustig finde, weil man echt gar nichts zu tun hat.
Aber ja, also
wer braucht dazu ein Game?
Und da fahren die dann so lang
und dann ist da das beste UI-Design
der Videospielgeschichte
und plötzlich bist du in Need for Speed Payback
gelandet. Fährt in der
Show jemand geradeaus, fährst
du nun selbst geradeaus.
Das macht man sehr oft.
Stirbt in der Show fast jemand durch einen Unfall,
stirbst du nun selbst fast durch diesen
Unfall. Das macht man
nicht so oft.
Ein spielbares DVD-Menü.
Ein interaktives Best-of.
Tief verborgen unter chromatischer
Aberration. Von
Family Guy Funny Moments zu
Wer braucht so ne Kacke?
Tour Funny Moments.
Die Fachpresse meint zwar, dass das Spiel absolut
nicht gut sei, aber ganz ehrlich,
wer kauft sich sowas für Streckendesign
oder Fahrzeughändling,
wenn der gesamte Reiz doch offensichtlich darin
liegt, Gewalttäter mittleren Alters beim
Lenken zu helfen? Für die Zielgruppe
hat's sicher Charme. Der typische
Fall von Fans greifen zu,
alle anderen spielen Probe.
Das kostet grad 1,60 auf Steam.
Nicht, dass es jetzt auch irgendjemand
überprüfen könnte, denn wenn wir schon nicht
den Erfolg von anderen Rennspielen kopieren
können, kopieren wir halt deren
Business-Entscheidung. Wer braucht
schon Codemasters, die ihre Spiele alle
paar Jahre aus sämtlichen Stores nehmen,
wenn man sie auch schon nach
eineinhalb Jahren entfernen kann?
Okay, sorry Leute.
Wie gesagt, mir war nicht mal klar, dass es zu dieser Serie
überhaupt ein Spiel gegeben hat.
Und geschweige denn, warum man das spielen will.
Aber Lizenzen sind nun mal
teuer. Besonders zu einer selbstproduzierten
Show sind sie einfach astronomisch.
Wir müssen uns außerdem sowieso auf andere
Projekte konzentrieren. Das schreiben wir
im FAQ.
Im FAQ zum Auslauf.
Von Pissbottles.
Weil es ja auch so viel Arbeit
kosten würde, ein Spiel nicht zu löschen.
Fans der Show müssen
sich nun also wohl oder übel
mit jedem anderen
Rennspiel jemals zufrieden geben.
Oder mit der Demo von Probe.
Breakaway ist oder war oder wird nie
ein Hero-Based-Spot.
Von der Existenz
dieses Spiels habe ich auch nie was gehört.
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie so ein
Arena-Battle-Game.
So ein bisschen was wie
Battle Read oder Battle Ride
oder wie das hieß.
Das im Subgenre der
Nein, danke, ich will Smite nicht spielen.
Ah, Smite, okay.
Also bei dem so, ähm, also bei dem so
Heroes rumlaufen.
Und da ist ein Ball.
Und der Sound klingt die ganze Zeit so komisch.
Ach du Scheiße.
Also, okay, das ist ja auch wirklich mal
komplette Vernichtung von Ressourcen,
was Amazon da macht.
Weil ich gehe mal davon aus, dass keiner der Leute,
die da dran arbeiten, wirklich Bock hatte
da dran zu arbeiten.
Das Spiel kombiniert Elemente
von Rocket League...
Moment, hab ich das... Moment,
hab ich das richtig gesehen?
Relay Esports.
Dass die wirklich versucht haben,
da irgendwie einen auf Esports zu machen in dem Game.
Na gut.
Dass das irgendwelche Teams sind.
Elemente von Rocket League,
Powerstone und League of Legends.
Was ist Powerstone?
...designt, sehr leicht und komfortabel auf Twitch gestreamt zu werden.
Wenn wir nochmal in den Sack greifen,
kriegen wir vielleicht sogar noch ein paar mehr Spielennamen
aufgelistet.
Außerdem ist es mittlerweile relativ schwierig geworden,
etwas auf Twitch zu streamen, das auf
grundmangelnder Nachfrage gar nicht erst erschienen ist.
Ich geb dem Spiel drei...
Hat Amazon eigentlich mittlerweile mal irgendwie
was halbwegs Erfolgreiches rausgebracht?
Das Einzige, was mir dazu einfällt, ist,
die bringen ja demnächst ein MMO
und bisher waren die Stimmen
nach den Beta-Tests ganz okay,
was ich so von den Leuten gehört hab.
Manche Sachen fanden das extrem nice,
manche haben gesagt, ja, ganz unterhaltsam,
aber...
Genau, New World, genau.
Aber ich hab jetzt wenig Leute gehört,
die zu New World gesagt haben,
Alter, das ist der Ultra-Crap schlechthin.
Also New World scheint wohl das erste
halbwegs
ganz okay-mäßige Spiel zu sein
von Amazon.
Wollen die nicht auch ein neues
Herr-der-Ringe-Game machen zu ihrer neuen
Herr-der-Ringe-Serie?
Zu guter Letzt schauen wir uns nochmal an,
was aus New World so wurde.
Das sollte ja mal rauskommen.
Das wird ja eventuell nächstes Jahr.
Die haben aber, man muss aber sagen,
mit New World, die haben da auch wieder
ein paar Dinger gemacht, wo ich mir gedacht hab,
das ist auch ein bisschen fragwürdig,
zum Beispiel
sollte dieses Game ja ursprünglich mal
ziemlich PvP-Fokus werden
und dann ist ihnen aufgefallen, dass irgendwie
rein mit PvP-Fokus nichts zu holen ist
und jetzt ist es irgendwie so
ein PvP-PvM-Hybrid
oder so.
Ob das so gut ist? Mal gucken.
Ich hab die Beta nicht gespielt.
Oder so vielleicht mal rauskommen.
Ein MMORPG
von und für Leute, die hoffen, dass es nicht
noch einmal verschoben wird, worüber die
meiste Berichterstattung bisher eher
negativ war. Polygon bezeichnete
den Inhalt des Spiels als fragwürdig.
IGN macht eins dieser
Alles-was-wir-bisher-wissen-Videos,
in dem sie dann auf sieben Minuten gestreckt sagen,
dass sie noch gar nicht so viel wissen.
Und ich warte schon seit Tagen darauf, dass Amazon endlich meine...
Also, ich, ich, wie gesagt,
ich hab's selbst nicht gespielt, aber alles,
was ich bisher von Leuten, den ich halt
auf Twitter-Folge so gelesen hab, die das gespielt haben,
es war nichts dabei,
was jetzt, wo das
das Ultrascheiße fand.
Da Lost hat's gespielt, der fand's ganz
okay. Äh, der, ähm,
Dings hier, wie heißt
er, der, der, wie heißt der Channel?
Der Sascha, wie heißt da von ihm nochmal der Channel?
Overwatch, äh, Heroes? Nee, äh,
wie heißt er denn? Ich bin grad voll,
steh grad voll auf dem Schlauch.
Ähm, wie heißt, wie heißt
denn der Channel von dem? Overwatch?
Highscore Heroes. Highscore Heroes, genau.
Der hat's auch gespielt, der fand's extrem
nice. Ähm,
ja, paar Leute auf der, deswegen, also
alles, was ich bisher zu dem Game gehört hab und auch
was ich so ein bisschen, ein bisschen
Reddit-mäßig gelesen hab, war
ganz in Ordnung. Also
nichts zu vergleichen mit dem anderen
Fail, was Amazon bisher abgeliefert hat.
Also, New World könnte tatsächlich ganz
okay werden.
... eine Bestellung losschickt, weil ich ohne Socken nicht wirklich einkaufen
gehen kann. 0 zu 3 gegen euch
also. Hoffentlich
wird's der massive Erfolg, den man sich
verspricht. Nee, wird's nicht. Dann,
das glaub ich nicht. Also, das, das glaub ich nicht.
Also, da fehlt, da fehlt New World
mit Sicherheit wirklich der, so,
der, der, der geniale
Funke irgendwie, dass das so ein,
wie, wie hat man früher gesagt, der World of Warcraft
Killer wird? Nee, ich glaub, das
können wir uns ja eh abschminken, das juckt ja auch
keinem mehr. Aber, dass das ein Game ist, was
Millionen Leute da reinbringt,
ins MMO, glaub ich nicht. Vor allem Spiele
mit heftigem PvP-Fokus
sind jetzt allgemein nicht so
beliebt, was
äh, Millionen an Spieler zahlen.
geht. WoW hat ja
auch keinen heftigen PvP-Fokus.
WoW hat einen nicen, äh,
mal zumindest früher, einen nicen
Arena-Modus gehabt, wo es auch wirklich darum
geht, dass die Leute gut spielen konnten, aber das war nie
der Hauptfokus von dem Game.
Und,
naja.
Zwei Jahre online oder so.
Irgendjemand
ist bestimmt gespannt.
Und das
doch, tatsächlich,
da muss ich dem Thema widersprechen.
Ich bin wirklich gespannt, was aus New World
wird. Ich glaube
wie gesagt nicht, dass es der nächste neue, krasse
Wow-Killer oder sowas wird.
Aber ich bin wirklich gespannt, was daraus wird, weil
ein PvP-Fokus
MMO, da gibt's meiner Meinung nach
viel zu wenige, die halt auch
irgendwie
langfristig Spaß machen, ja.
Mal gucken. Mal gucken.
Ich glaube aber auch nicht, dass es der Riesen-Mega-Erfolg
wird.
...
Ja, das ist das, was ich vorhin auch
mal... Das ist riesen Ressourcen-Verschwendung,
Alter, was Amazon da treibt.
...
FLIFF! Alter, Herz 93, FLIFF!
Was buddelst du jetzt mit uralte MMOs aus, Alter?
Camelot... Äh äh äh äh...
Dings, nee, heißt ja immer noch so, Camelot Unchained soll ja auch demnächst rauskommen.
Ja, nee, wird nie rauskommen wahrscheinlich.
Wenn es denn überhaupt möglich wäre.
Schalten wir den Joke-Mode aber für einen Moment mal wieder aus.
Ich finde es unglaublich, mit was für einer Arroganz und Selbstsicherheit Amazon in diese Industrie eingestiegen ist.
Mit den größten Plänen von einer großen internen Engine, einem Spiel, das...
Ja, Amazon kann ja gar nicht anders.
Das ist Amazon. Amazon kann ja nicht irgendwie einsteigen und sagen, ja, gucken wir mal, wie sich das Ganze so entwickelt.
Die machen, das sind Stonks, Leute, die machen immer erstmal auf große, auf dicke Hose, ohne dass was dahinter ist.
... erobern sollte, dem großen MMO schlechthin und sobald neue Spiele unter neuen Marken...
Ja, der Gamer Alex irgendwie ungefähr sieben Jahre, ja, und es ist nicht mal ansatzweise vorzeigbar.
... wurden sie schnurstracks einem nach dem anderen exekutiert.
Ist eigentlich, wie sieht es eigentlich mit Star Citizen aus mittlerweile?
... gewesen, machen sie einfach weiter mit mehr und mehr.
Konzepte erdacht von Führungspositionen, die nur eine Tech der Tech-Willen showcasen sollen und man dann stolz auf seine 10.000 Spieler gleichzeitig sein kann.
Der Inhalt ist erstmal zweitrangig.
Seid einfach unfassbar teuer.
Das ist unser nächstes Spiel.
Teuer.
Und um den ganzen Amt...
... und am Ende noch seine Krone aufzusetzen, haben sie ihren großen Cloud-Gaming-Streaming-Service-TM ange...
Ach, das habe ich ja schon wieder komplett verdrängt.
Amazon will ja bei dem ganzen Game-Streaming-Geschiss auch noch mitmachen.
Jetzt muss Kasaume interessiert, ja, und Stadia ja ein riesen Erfolg geworden ist, von dem alle gerechnet haben, ja.
Man muss sich ja immer mal nur die Spieler bei Destiny angucken.
Stadia ist da bei einem Prozent.
Aufgerundet.
... gekündigt.
Um damit, so bete ich...
Äh, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Hein...
Deny...
07.
Excellent Subscription.
... so hart auf die Schnauze zu fallen.
Denn das, was die Welt am meisten braucht...
Cooper, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den Sub.
... ist ein weiterer Gaming-Service, der Videospiele wie austauschbare Netflix-Produktionen behandelt.
Nee, aber...
Amazon ist bei der Sache echt ein bisschen spät, ne?
Die haben alle angefangen, wo Stadia losgelegt ist und nach dem...
Oh nee, Google macht Spielestreaming.
Wir brauchen jetzt auch ganz schnell Spielestreaming.
Oder man hatte vielleicht schon Spielestreaming.
Und dann hat man festgekriegt, oh nee, bei Google läuft nicht so gut.
Ah nee, da brauchen wir auch kein Spielestreaming mehr.
... handeln wird.
Von einer Firma, die so schon mit ihren eigenen Spielen umgeht.
Und die erst vor kurzem darauf bestanden hat, dass Kunden ihre selbst erworbenen Produkte gar nicht besitzen.
Und man sich das Recht vorbehalten möchte, Kunden diesen digitalen Besitz wieder wegzunehmen.
Ja, das hat...
Das war auch...
Das ist auch geil, ne?
Wenn du dir ein Video kaufst bei Prime, da können sie dann sagen, ach nö.
Äh, äh, nö.
Gibt sie mir.
Ja.
Aber wenn man da schon so hinterher sein möchte, sind Videospiele nicht weit.
Es passiert echt nicht häufig, dass man gleich alle Masken auf einmal fallen lässt.
Wobei sie in diesem Kampf gegen Konsumenten ja sowieso genug Gleichgesinnte finden würden.
Das ist nicht nur dreist, sondern in dieser Kombination auch noch erstaunlich gefährlich.
Amazon hat jetzt schon, in diesem kurzen Zeitraum, den ich hier beleuchtet habe,
deutlich bewiesen, wie egal ihnen Videospiele an sich sind.
Das stimmt.
Wie wenig Respekt sie für ein Medium...
Amazon...
Das...
Amazon geht das auch komplett am Arsch vorbei.
Amazon stochert so lange im Dunkeln, bis da vielleicht mal ein Hit rauskommt.
Oder was halbwegs brauchbares.
Und das wird dann gemolken bis zum Gehtnichtmehr.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, dass Amazon Flappy Bird gekauft hat?
Wer kann sich da noch dran erinnern?
Flappy Bird, das... äh, war auch so ein Ding, wo man nicht verstanden hat.
Naja, egal.
Den Machern von diesem Medium und den Konsumenten haben.
Sie haben bewiesen, dass sie auch in diesem Bereich nicht mit Samthandschuhen angefasst werden sollten,
dass man zukünftigen Projekten kritisch und skeptisch gegenüberstehen sollte
und sie abseits vom Versandhaus möglichst wenig mit Gaming und der Gaming-Szene an sich zu tun haben sollten.
Ich bin nun übrigens auch wieder auf Twitch unterwegs,
weil alle anderen Streaming-Plattformen langsam pleite gehen, außer PlexStorm.
Folgt mir also am besten auch mal dort.
Wir haben da immer ne lustige Zeit.
Was für nen Ding?
Plex, was?
... und spielt ab und zu meinen Videospiel...
... seit es von damals...
Excellent.
Ah, hat's verlinkt. So, so muss das sein. Excellent.
Bisschen Promotion muss immer sein.
Ja, hat er recht.
Ihr habt bisher nichts Gescheites auf die Reihe gebracht.
Und die werden in nächster Zeit, denke ich, auch nichts richtig Gescheites auf die Reihe bringen.
Wann New World rauskommt, sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber ich bin tatsächlich auf New World ein bisschen gespannt.
Ne, ich glaub, der hat auch kein Intro mehr.
Intros gehen auf YouTube 2020 nicht mehr.
Oder nicht mehr gut.
Boah, Leute, ich bin immer noch müde.
Wie geht denn das?
Boah, ich bin jetzt schon seit zwei Stunden oder so an.
Aber ich penn gleich ein.
Und ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Das ist eine schlechte Kombination.
In US-YouTube-Regionen gibt es viele Intros.
Es gibt noch einige Channels mit Intros, ja, aber...
ähm...
Die meisten haben entweder keine Intros oder die machen es besonders trickreich.
Die machen irgendeinen Teaser von 30 Sekunden, dann ein kurzes Intro und dann geht's von vorne los.
Warum kommen Intros nicht gut?
Weil die Leute kaum noch Aufmerksamkeitsspanne haben.
Wenn du das Video direkt mit einem Intro anfängst, sind die Leute nach fünf Sekunden direkt weg.
Du musst einen Teaser machen, dann ein Intro und dann mit dem Video anfangen.
Das geht.
Aber direkt am Anfang den Intro kannst du nicht mehr machen.
Knupp.
Excellent.
Funktioniert nicht mehr.
Schauen wir uns das jetzt noch an.
Komm, wir gucken uns das noch eine Runde Battlefield 4 Top...
Top Plays an.
Muss jetzt, muss jetzt mal sein.
Morgen kommt, äh, kommt Venice Unleashed raus.
Oder, oder um nicht zu sagen...
Moment, Moment.
Hab ich sie noch drinne?
Ne.
Hab ich nicht mehr drinne.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Venice Unleashed.
Kommt morgen raus, genau.
Was ja auch für Erheiterung im letzten Video gesorgt hat.
Da wollten Leute wirklich wissen, wie ich das...
Wie nice, wie ich das gemacht hab.
Venice Unleashed.
Natürlich wird das nicht verraten.
Das ist Streamgeheimnis.
So, gucken wir uns mal ne Runde Battlefield 4 an.
Schreckt.
Wie?
Warum fällt der Dude nicht um?
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Da hat man aber auch gesehen, Battlefield Server und Tickrate, ne?
Weil, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen...
Das eine hat mit dem anderen jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu tun, was man da sieht und was da passiert, ja?
Hello and welcome to the Battlefield 4 Top Plays.
Guckt euch mal an.
Also, das, was man sieht und das, was passiert, hat nicht so wirklich gesynct miteinander.
Hitting that headshot at range, on road transmission, on a freefaller.
Incredible stuff.
Now, keeping it with some sniping clips.
Ha, ha, ha.
Got this one from Ascend High Sound.
It's using the CS5.
He's getting a 7-Man on Paracels.
Bam.
Oh, da wird er gequickscoped.
Der muss noch ne 360 einbauen.
Dann ist das legit.
Ansonsten zählt das nicht.
Hopp.
Nicht abgenommen.
Nicht legit.
He did send in a few clips.
The second one is again a sniping clip using the CS on Dawnbreaker.
An 8-Man in total for this one.
Ah, der ist voll reingesprungen, der Typ.
Da sitzt der Neck hinten.
Die map heißt auf Deutsch übrigens Morgen-Dämmerer.
So, das war's.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Der Morgen-Dämmerer.
Alles klar.
Der wird krass geflamed der Dude danach.
Shotgun-Typ mit Killstreak, der kriegt also wenn's, es ist PC, es ist keine Xbox und es
ist keine PlayStation, der würde ansonsten Hate-Voice-Messages bekommen danach.
Ja, das stimmt.
Die erste Map war das mit dem...
mit dem Radioteleskop, was vor ein paar
Wochen kaputt gegangen ist.
Oh, geil!
Warum ist der denn da jetzt mit?
Warum ist der denn mit explodiert jetzt?
Bam!
Warum explodiert...
Ah!
Hier, das ist ja
Golmo Trailway. Da liegt doch hier,
liegen doch versteckt so Bomben.
Da liegen doch auf der Strecke so, so, so,
so Minen rum.
Da hat er sich wahrscheinlich mit den Luft gesprengt.
Ja, genau!
Jetzt hab ich's kapiert.
Ach, guck mal, da hat der
anderen Panzer auch noch gebasht, oder wie?
Nee.
Was?
Ne Heli?
Wat?
Ach, da!
Alter, das hätt ich jetzt aber nicht gesehen.
Also, das war wirklich nicht aufgefallen.
Dass da noch ein Heli dabei ist.
Also mal ernsthaft, wer hat das gesehen am Anfang?
Ich hab jetzt den Panzer hier gesehen, okay,
aber dass da ein Heli rumgestellst, ist noch, nee.
Deswegen kriegt er auch so 30 Milliarden Punkte.
Das nächste Clip ist von walkablemango42.
Er ist auf Haynam Reservations.
Walkable Mango, alles klar.
... auf dem Tor, und schaut, was er danach macht.
Bam!
Look, what he does next.
Das könnte ein richtig guter Clickbait Titel sein.
Oder was auch sehr beliebt ist,
zehn Weihnachtsgeschenke, die jeder braucht.
Du wirst niemals glauben, was Nummer vier ist.
Oder, oder...
Unglaublicher Hack! Battlefield-Spieler hassen diesen Trick! Oder solche Dinger!
Das musst du erst mal treffen, das ist echt nicht ohne!
Genau, unglaubliche Entdeckung!
Beste Waffe in Battlefield, da muss am besten noch sowas dahinter, wie unglaubliche Entdeckung, beste Waffe in Battlefield, die niemand kennt, oder irgendwie sowas.
Oder die beste Waffe irgendwie, sodass die quasi jetzt erst entdeckt wurde und du bist der Erste, der es der Welt erzählt.
Na, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass in Bad Company 2 die Dinger viel langsamer und größer waren.
In Bad Company 2 so ein Transportheli mit dem AT-4 zu hitten, war jetzt nicht so...
...so krass schwer, es hing natürlich immer davon ab, wie gut der Typ geflogen ist, wenn der Typ richtig gut geflogen ist, war es saumäßig schwer, aber die meisten konnte man gut hitten, die Transport-Helikopter in Bad Company 2 waren ja auch recht langsam und fett, die Attack-Helikopter waren in Bad Company 2 auch größer und langsamer, in Battlefield 4 sind die Dinger halt viel schneller und kleiner.
Also das ist wirklich nicht ohne.
Du, du, du, du, du, du...
Ist das die Community-Map? Ich kenn die Map nicht.
Ah, okay.
Ich hab nichts gesagt.
Wisst ihr, was das Coole ist? Wenn Venice Unleashed wirklich gut ankommt...
...dann kann man die Dinger auch nicht mehr verändern.
Die haben ja sogar einen Map-Editor.
Und da kann man sowas theoretisch selbst machen.
Hidden Weapon found after 10 years in Battlefield 3.
Genau sowas.
Sowas musst du da machen.
Richtig.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist kein Feind.
Moment.
Woher wusste der, dass da einer ist?
Was ist da los?
Hat der an?
Ist das Release-Date von Venice Unleashed bekannt?
Ja, morgen.
Okay, okay.
Jetzt gucken wir mal.
Wo hat er das erkannt?
Ach, Moment.
Das ist doch ein...
Ach, das ist ein Gegner.
Das ist nur der Name-Tag.
Das ist nur der Name-Tag von einem Teammate hinten dran.
Das ist doch ein Gegner gewesen.
Ich dachte, das ist...
Ah, okay, okay.
Alles legit.
Legit.
Da hat er nochmal Glück gehabt.
Sonst hätte ich hier gleich meine langjährigen Dice-Kontakte benutzt.
Und da hätten wir gleich den...
Den dicker Nick.
Oder wer auch immer das ist.
Hätten wir gleich Instant...
Instant...
Vag-Band.
Ich hätte direkt...
Ich hätte direkt in Stockholm angerufen.
Ja.
Ich hab gesagt, hier, das geht nicht.
Der Dusty-Coin.
Nein, nein, nein.
Vag-Band.
Weil es das Game noch nicht mal Vag hat.
Oh.
Alter, die werden hart geschreckt, die Gegner.
Die kriegen ja sowas von aufs Maul, die Gegner.
Alter, Falda.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Es schießt auch keiner zurück.
Düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt.
War die Waffe von sich aus so genau?
Oder musste man zumindest noch ein bisschen Recoil-Control machen?
Alter, die kriegen auf den Sack.
Oh.
Zwei Clips von Tessio Bruno.
Der erste wird auf Operation Locker mit der CZ-3A1 sein.
Ein bisschen in diesem Korner hinter diesen Explosiv-Berlen.
Aber das wird ihn nicht stoppen, ein paar Kills zu packen.
Da stehen sie einfach rum und checken es nicht.
Also, Noob-Weapon war bei mir damals immer noch ACR.
Oder AC.
B?
Wie hieß das Ding?
Es gab beide.
Ne, es gab eine ACE-23 oder so und es gab eine ACWR oder so, ne?
Die waren beide richtig gut.
Also die AEK in Battlefield 3, muss ich euch sagen, ich hab lieber eine M16 oder eine M416 benutzt,
weil das Reload von der AEK...
Die AEK war halt wirklich lahm.
Vor allem, wenn du nicht aufgepasst hast.
Ähm.
Mit dem...
Und alles leer geschossen hast.
Alter, der hat...
Oh!
Also, man muss ja...
Eins muss man ja sagen, ne?
Die schaffen es echt immer, Gegner zu finden, die absolut braindead sind.
Aber so macht es halt Spaß, ne?
Wo man wieder sieht, fuck skill-based Matchmaking.
So muss das sein.
Du brauchst einfach...
Ab und zu mal irgendwelche krassen Achievements, ja?
Das ist...
Es erwartet ja keiner, dass es konstant so ist.
Sticking with Operation Locker, we've got a clip from Venom Helix.
A 17-Kill-Streak in less than a minute using the AEK.
This is super accurate stuff.
Man kommt morgen, wenn es unleashed raus, ne?
Wenn das dann irgendwie im 23er rauskommt oder so, spiele ich das auch nicht.
Accurate stuff.
I don't think he misses much at all.
Ich hoffe, die denken an EU-Time.
I'd be interested to see what his accuracy was for this game.
It's probably 30% or maybe a little bit higher.
Accurate stuff.
I really enjoyed this streak.
Das Geile ist bei den Gegnern, die reagieren noch nicht mal, wenn sie angeschossen werden.
Ja, keine Reaktion.
Der Typ kriegt in der S geschossen und dreht sich nicht mal um.
800er Ping-Chinese oder was ist das?
And finishing off today's episode, a Metro-Clip from Christopher2JJ.
Ah, yes.
The MG4 is his weapon of choice.
Lots of smoke.
Perfect, so he can stay concealed and get behind the other team.
Guck mal, hallo, Gegner, please.
Then set to work.
Mach die Augen auf.
Alter.
Guckt sie euch an.
Der macht das schon gut mit dem Flanken und alles.
Ich will jetzt nichts über das Spiel.
Aber die Gegner tragen halt schon einen beträchtlichen Teil dazu bei.
Battlefield 4 hatte so eine komische Mischung mit Tick-Rates.
Battlefield 4 hatte, ich frage mich nicht, was die default Tick-Rate ist,
aber die hatten in Battlefield 4 so ein komisches System eingebaut,
dass dort, wo Action auf der Map ist, die Tick-Rate höher ist,
als dort, wo keine Action ist.
Irgendwie so.
Das war, das war sehr merkwürdig.
Und haben sie auch erst nachträglich eingebaut.
Wenn ihr dieses Episode von Battlefield Top plays,
wenn ihr es genießt,
dann lasst euch gerne ein Abo da unten.
Wenn ihr eure Clips habt,
dann könnt ihr diese Battlefield-Tipps kennen.
Das kennen wir schon, ne?
Übrigens, das ist wirklich beste Pose im ganzen Game.
Ja, ja, das kennen wir schon.
Das kennen wir schon, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Wurden sie weggebashed.
Battlefield 3 nervt einfach, dass man um die Ecke ist,
und drei Sekunden später stirbt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Dafür gefällt mir Battlefield 3 an sich vom Gameplay her am besten.
Also, Chat.
Hier muss man übelst aufs Klo, aber...
Ich habe jetzt keinen Bock, Stream auszumachen.
Wir gucken jetzt noch was zusammen.
Haben wir denn hier noch Interessantes zu gucken?
Opening a log with explosives.
Excellent.
This is the lockpicking lawyer, and today...
Das war 2017.
...independence day in the United States.
Ah, yes.
We are currently celebrating the 241st anniversary of the 13 colonies,
declaring that they were a new nation independent of the British Empire.
And I wanted to come up with an appropriate way to mark this occasion,
so I figured a good way to do that would be for me,
an American lockpicker, to pick a British.
So I went through my collection, looking for a British lock I've not shown you before,
and I came up with this Squire WS-75, which is made in Britain,
and how perfect is that, it even has the British flag on it.
But then it occurred to me...
Eins muss man ja sagen, in einem Punkt ist UK wirklich größer US.
Und das ist bei den Einheiten.
Ich meine, in den USA, wenn du bei Amazon guckst, wie schwer ist eine Maus,
dann steht da irgendwie...
...einmal ein paar Sachen.
7,3 Unzen oder sowas.
Wo so ounces, was zum Teufel soll das sein?
Also was Einheiten angeht, ist wirklich...
Freedom Units ist schlimm.
Da sind die in England besser.
Die verwenden wenigstens zum größten Teil normale Units.
Und die haben auch wenigstens ein Datum in der richtigen Reihenfolge in England.
Don't do that by picking a lock.
How do we do it in the United States for the 4th of July?
We all get together, we have picnics, we set meat on fire.
Ja, okay.
70%
Oh, oh, jetzt wird's aufgesprengt.
... traditionally set off fireworks today.
I figured I would use a traditional fireworks pyrotechnic mixture.
Hast du schon von der Paketabgabe gehört für den Onlinehandel?
Ne, was soll das sein?
I'm going to mix up a little bit of potassium perchlorate, 70%,
with some 2 to 3 micron aluminum powder, 30% of that.
I may add a little bit of fumed silica as well, which will do three things.
First, it'll cut down on static, making this...
Es war doch sogar mal so, dass bei der internationalen...
... Raumstation was nicht gepasst hat, weil die einen in Freedom Units gerechnet haben...
... und die anderen metrisch.
... for operation.
Second, it'll make it flow better, which I need it to flow quite well...
... when we insert it into the lock.
And finally, it makes the mixture burn much, much faster.
Once we have that done, we're going to take this...
Das war eine Rakete, kann sein.
Aber ich kann mich nur daran erinnern, dass es halt versagt hat, weil die Einheiten unterschiedlich waren.
And we're going to...
... insert through this tiny little hole here.
That's why we need it to flow well.
Probably roughly 50 milligrams of the mixture.
Auf.
... have it in there.
Spring's in die Luft.
... this little igniter that I made just for the occasion.
Slip it through that crack as well.
And finally, we're going to cap it off with a little bit of 5-minute epoxy.
Now, the idea is that...
... to blow this retainer cap right out of the lock.
Excellent.
The only thing that's holding it in is a screw that comes right down here.
Ja, ich will einfach nur sehen, wie es explodiert, Alter.
Lad auf.
Oder füll es rein.
... into a steel box that I put together.
It is safe in there.
I will attack and I don't want to do this around the camera.
Oh, da hat es sogar so ein extra Start-Ding.
So, we're going to cut the video.
I'm going to put everything together.
And once we've got everything...
Wie? Ich will sehen, wie wir das reinfangen.
... wie das reinfüllt.
... or later and everything seems to have gone according to plan.
I mix the powder up.
Wir dürfen gar nicht zugucken, wie das reinfüllt.
Oh.
And it flowed perfectly into the gap between the core and retainer plate.
Once the powder was in, I slid the igniter into place
and capped everything off with a 5-minute epoxy.
Wahrscheinlich darfst du das auf YouTube nicht zeigen, weil dann YouTube das Video sperrt.
... to ensure that the pressure builds such that there's enough force
to shear that screw and knock the retainer plate out.
Okay, wo explodiert's?
Ah!
Excellent.
Oh, RIP, Kamera.
Success, my friends.
Though certainly not with my filming technique.
What had happened was, I duct-taped the camera to the 1-inch thick...
Okay, und jetzt ist es aufgesprengt.
Okay, ähm...
Oh, wow!
Okay, das hat's mit...
... hat's mitgenommen.
... which is absolutely remarkable.
In addition, there is in perfect...
RIP-Schloss.
... a great way to celebrate Independence Day.
Jawoll!
Also, wenn das nicht ein super amerikanischer Weg ist, Independence Day zu celebraten,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Wir sprengen was in die Luft.
Also, mehr Kokona-Style geht ja eigentlich gar nicht.
Wie ist eigentlich jetzt, wo wir gerade beim In-die-Luft-Sprengen sind?
Habt ihr das verfolgt?
Ist es jetzt erlaubt oder verboten, Feuerwerk zu machen an Silvester?
Mich persönlich tangiert's ja nur so am Rande.
Ich mach ja schon seit Jahren kein Feuerwerk mehr.
Erlaubt, aber es ist nicht mehr kaufbar.
Okay.
Das bedeutet, die Leute kaufen sich das dann im Ausland, oder wie?
Okay, okay.
Hessen...
Gucken wir mal.
Also, an diesen Orten...
... in diesen Regionen gilt wegen Corona ein Feuerwerksverbot.
Also...
Offenbach?
Also, Haftbefehl darf nicht Böller.
Also...
Okay, es gibt ein Verkaufsverbot.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das geht doch voll nach hinten los, oder?
Also, wenn es ein Verkaufsverbot von Feuerwerk gibt, die Leute bestellen sich einfach ihr Feuerwerk.
Oder holen sich das aus Polen oder sonst wo.
Oder bei AliExpress.
Kann man bei AliExpress Feuerwerk bestellen?
Ja, man kann bei AliExpress Feuerwerk bestellen.
Nee, das ist gar kein Feuerwerk.
Das ist gar kein Feuerwerk.
Das ist kein Feuerwerk.
Das sieht nur so aus.
Okay, okay, gibt's nicht.
Okay, kann man nicht bestellen.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass viele Leute das entweder bestellen, nach Polen fahren oder sonst wie.
Das geht doch meistens nach hinten los, oder?
Dann sprengen sich noch mehr Leute die Hände ab, weil sie Crap-Feuerwerk kaufen.
Oder selbst bauen, ja, wer es kann.
Naja.
Ehrlich gesagt, ist mir das wurscht.
Ich weiß halt schon genug Leute, die das gerne geben.
Den gönne ich das irgendwo, also sollen das ruhig machen, aber mich juckt's, mich juckt's nicht.
Stimmt, ja, wer in die Metro darf, kann sich da wahrscheinlich holen, oder konnte sich das holen.
Okay, was will uns der Typ mit seinem Favorite Desktop sagen?
Das Video sticht mir so ins Auge.
Also, Tanjim the Tech Guy.
Was, was will er?
This is what's...
Wer will denn sowas haben?
Ich will nicht, dass mein Desktop so aussieht.
Ich will, dass mein Desktop so aussieht.
Also, also jetzt mal ernsthaft, Chat, wenn ihr die Auswahl habt zwischen diesem Desktop hier.
Zwischen dem Desktop und dem Desktop, was nehmt ihr?
Was ist besser?
Meiner, ja, eindeutig.
Ja, aber wozu, das ist total un...
Auch noch Powerpoint-Präsentation, Alter, was will der Typ denn jetzt?
Wer braucht sowas?
Das ist doch total unergonomisch.
Und warum, warum Powerpoint?
Der hat doch nicht mal ne Taskleiste.
Das ist total unergonomisch.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch, dass er auf nen Kaktus klicken kann.
Jetzt passiert irgendwas.
Ach du große Kacke, wer braucht denn sowas?
Ih!
Nein!
Wer will denn sowas haben?
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch der obligatorische League of Legends Link oder sowas auf dem Desktop.
Ne, nein!
Alter!
Warum sollte man sich seinen Rechner so verstellen?
Und dann irgendwelche komischen Dinger aus, aus frag mich nicht worunter laden.
Omnimomo-Info, was auch immer.
Warum sollte ich sowas installieren?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Dann noch irgendwelche Themes von Google Drive.
Also wenn du danach 20 Kilo gehast, musst du dich ja net wundern.
Ne.
Ne, das ist Schwachsinn, Alter.
Was ein Schwachsinn.
Warum hat er so viele gute Bewertungen?
Ja, ja.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ne, ne.
Geh weg.
Kurz Soundtrack.
Excellent.
Ich glaub Videomusik, äh, Videospielemusik darf man auch spielen.
Ketchem.
Excellent.
Können wir in einem Stream das ASCII-Feuerwerk programmieren?
Ne, weil da wirst du jetzt aus dem Stehkreis nicht, wie es geht.
Da wirst du erst mal Gedanken drüber machen.
Das kann man übrigens auch super in der Loop laufen lassen, ne?
Das ist ja der Soundtrack, der das Game über quasi zu 90% im Loop läuft.
Das ASCII-Quarm ist ein Perl-Skript, ja.
So hört sich übrigens 8-Bit-Musik an, die mit modernen Tools erstellt wurde und eigentlich nicht 8-Bit ist.
Deutlich besser als auf dem NES oder so.
So, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Wie Apple dich manipuliert.
Apple muss mich gar nicht manipulieren.
Die Apple-Fanboys bringen Apple schon genug Geld.
Zumal sich die Fanboys auch gar nicht mehr...
Du musst die Fanboys auch gar nicht mehr...
Haben wir das schon mal geguckt?
Du musst die Fanboys auch gar nicht mehr weiter manipulieren.
Die sind selbst so sehr schon da drin gefangen in dieser Denkweise,
dass die, egal wie scheiße sich die Firma verhält, das immer noch weiter loben,
weil sonst müssten sie sich eingestehen, dass sie was falsches fanboyt haben die letzten Jahre.
Excellent.
Ja, dann gucken wir uns mal, wie uns Apple manipuliert.
Wie manipuliert uns Apple?
Manipuliert uns Apple.
So ist es leider mit fast allen Fanboys.
Ja, ist so.
Egal ob Nvidia, AMD, Android, iOS, Apple, was auch immer.
Also macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Xbox, Playstation.
Man hat das ja damals immer gesehen, wenn es um 360 oder PS3 ging,
wie krass da beide Seiten gefanboyt haben.
Eigentlich total unnötig.
Letztendlich macht ein sinnloses Fanboy nur blind dafür, wenn die Firma irgendeine Scheiße baut.
Und man es trotzdem supportet.
Eigentlich ist Fanboyen richtig doof.
Aber bei Handys redet man nur von Apple-Fanboys.
Nö.
Es gibt genug Android-Fanboys.
Aber wir wissen ja, dass das einzig wahre E-PC ist.
Bei allem.
PCMR, Leute.
24 FPS reichen.
Ja, mit zwei Augen bist du schon bei 48.
Okay, excellent.
Also dann gucken wir uns mal an, wie uns Apple verarscht.
2016 hat das bestmögliche iPhone 1.119 Euro gekostet.
2020 1.558,65 Euro.
Das ist ein fast 40%iger...
Ja, und wisst ihr, was das geile ist?
Wisst ihr, was das geile ist?
Die Apple-Fanboys, die Apple-Fanboys, die sagen jetzt,
ja, das ist doch gar nicht so schlimm,
weil du musst dir das ja nicht kaufen.
Und du kannst dir ja auch einfach ein altes, schlechteres kaufen.
Das ist ja überhaupt kein Problem.
Das heißt, lass Apple das doch machen.
Oder es gibt die anderen Fanboys, die sagen,
ja, die haben ja auch das iPhone total krass verbessert.
Da kann man schon mal 500 Euro mehr für ausgeben.
Man kann sich das immer irgendwie zurechtlegen.
Der Preisanstieg innerhalb von...
Deswegen, ganz ehrlich, meiner Ansicht nach...
Ich weiß, ich habe selbst ein Apple...
Was habe ich denn für eins?
XR oder so?
Ich glaube, ich habe einen XR.
Meiner Meinung nach das beste iPhone ist das aktuelle iPhone SE.
Das ist preislich das, was du früher für ein Top-Smartphone bezahlt hast
und ist vollkommen ausreichend.
5 Jahre. Apple-Produkte kosten...
Ja klar, ja klar. Die anderen Hersteller machen da mit.
Android-Handys sind auch übertrieben viel teurer.
Also zumindest die High-End-Modelle mit 75 Kameras.
Viel, viel Geld. Aber das Geschäft boomt unverändert.
Die Firma ist das wertvollste Unternehmen der Welt
und eines der profitabelsten.
Warum geben die Leute Apple so gerne so viel Geld?
Weil sie Apple-Fanboys sind.
Okay, das hat viele Gründe.
Aber wir fokussieren uns heute auf eine ganz bestimmte Strategie.
Ich meine das neue SE.
Nicht das 2016er SE.
Oder auch, wie man wahnsinnig hohe Preise irgendwie logisch wirken lässt.
Das ist kein Ding.
Also, hohe Preise logisch wirken lassen, ist das einfachste von der Welt.
Du musst einfach... Wow.
What the fuck?
Falsche Emote geklickt gerade.
Hohe Preise logisch wirken lassen, ist das einfachste von der Welt.
Du musst einfach nur einen Vergleich schaffen,
der den hohen Preis nicht mehr so hoch erscheinen lässt.
Zum Beispiel, du bietest ein Game an mit einem Monats-Abo von 10 Euro.
Wo es im Endeffekt außer ein bisschen Ingame-Währung nichts für gibt.
So, und jetzt bietest du die Ingame-Währung aber auch zum Kaufen zusätzlich an.
Angenommen, du kannst dir die Ingame-Währung kaufen für irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 10 Goldstücke für 10 Euro.
So.
Oder, du kannst ein Monats-Abo abschließen für 9 Euro und du bekommst 15 Goldstücke.
Und dann sagen die Leute auch dann,
Ho, Poggers!
Wer ist denn so dumm und kauft sich das Normale?
Ich kauf mir das Monats-Abo!
So, ganz einfach.
Und schon denken die Leute, sie haben wahnsinnig geile Schnäppchen gemacht.
Dabei wurden sie übelst...
Übelst Hardcore-Chibades.
Hardcore-Chibaded vom Hersteller.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Und um nicht zu sagen, genau...
Ja, BitConnect hat es auf eine andere Art und Weise probiert.
BitConnect hat die Taktik gemacht, so, morgen gibt es nichts mehr.
So.
Ihr müsst jetzt, jetzt alle mitmachen. Alle sind schon dabei.
Wie, ihr seid noch nicht dabei? Ihr müsst jetzt auch dabei sein.
BitConnect, yeah!
Und dann, oh, wir machen dicht.
Sagen wir, wir wollen ein neues Handy kaufen.
Von Apple.
Um überhaupt zu dieser Entscheidung zu gelangen, haben wir schon einen weiten Weg zurückgelegt.
So elegant, so schön, die Werbung war so toll.
Ah, yes.
Der Kumpel schwört drauf und die werden nicht so schnell langsam und damn sind die...
Das stimmt nicht.
Ich verwende ja immer noch ein iPhone, also habe ich noch als zweites ein iPhone 6.
Alter, ist das mittlerweile unbenutzbar.
Okay, dann investieren wir halt mal.
Jetzt stehen wir vor einer wichtigen Abwägung.
Wir geben Geld aus.
Aber wie viel?
Und hier hilft uns Apple, wie kaum ein anderes Unternehmen, zu der einzig richtigen Entscheidung zu kommen.
Ganz viel.
Das ist das Ziel von Upselling.
Dass ein Kunde bei einem jeweiligen Kauf möglichst viel Geld ausgibt.
Ein Autohändler macht das wahrscheinlich recht aggressiv.
Oh ja, das Leder ist wirklich bequem, das kann ich nur empfehlen, das lohnt sich und so weiter.
Er will den finalen Kaufpreis des Autos in die Höhe treiben.
Klassischerweise durch eine luxuriöse...
Ich glaube mein Autoradio, mein Autoradio ist mehr wert als mein Auto.
Liegt aber auch daran, weil mein Auto ein olles Kackding ist und das Radio halt zusätzlich gekauft ist.
Inneneinrichtung oder vielleicht eine bessere Anlage.
Apple ist da deutlich subtiler.
Schauen wir uns dafür die Website an.
Wir scrollen etwas, die Produkte werden vorgestellt.
Dann kommen wir zu einem Abschnitt namens, welches iPhone ist das richtige für dich?
Naja, natürlich teures.
Wir könnten uns das iPhone SE holen für 466,90 Euro.
Ja, beste. Ohne Scheiß, meiner Meinung nach das beste iPhone, was man sich kaufen kann aktuell.
Das neue iPhone SE.
Vor allem, es ist auch in einer sinnvollen Größe für ein Smartphone.
Es ist nice, ich gebe es zu.
Es ist schon cool, wenn man ein bisschen größeres Handy hat.
Aber von der Größe und für die Hosentasche her...
...muss ich persönlich sagen, ist die Größe das Beste.
Und auch preis-leistungsmäßig, da kannst du echt nichts sagen.
...haben wir uns so überlegt.
Das ist aber relativ klein und die Kamera ist irgendwie auch nicht so geil.
Die Kamera ist eigentlich relativ gut.
Wenn du jetzt nicht gerade künstlerisch exquisite ausgefallene Bilder machen willst, reicht es voll und ganz.
Ultraweitwinkel.
Aber guck, das iPhone 11 kostet nur ungefähr 2 Euro.
Wenn wir schon Geld für ein gutes Handy ausgeben, dann ist das vielleicht auch noch drin.
Wobei, da nur etwas über 100 Euro drauf und wir sind schon beim 12er mit besserem Chip.
Ist im Prinzip das Gleiche wie mit der In-Gam, wie ich vorhin auch gesagt habe.
Und noch viel besserer Kamera und auch 5G und so.
Das Pro ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel.
Wobei, boah, die Kamera ist echt so sick und die halten auch ewig.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, man muss auch nicht übertreiben.
Mini, das ist schon ziemlich klein, oder?
Wir schauen ja schon viele Videos auf dem Handy und so.
Und 36,51 Euro pro Monat.
5,4 Zoll Display ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Doch nicht so viel.
Alter, das ist huge.
36 Euro im Monat für wie lang?
Wie lang?
Für die nächsten 100 Jahre?
Ne, für die nächsten, frag mich nicht, 2 Jahre oder so?
Oh, das Blau ist schön.
Wie viel Speicher brauchen wir denn?
64.
Immer.
Ich nehme immer das kleinste.
Ich glaube, ich bin absolut nicht der richtige Typ, der für diese Art von Marketing empfänglich ist.
60 GB ist vielleicht etwas wenig.
256 GB ist vielleicht ein bisschen unnötig.
Aber 180...
Ohne Scheiß, ich nehme fast immer das kleinste.
Weil ich höre darauf kaum Musik, die auf dem Handy gespeichert ist.
Und 64G Apps reicht komplett aus.
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Wo sieht man denn, wie viel Speicherplatz das Handy aktuell hat?
Sieht man bestimmt irgendwo in den Settings.
Nein, ich will jetzt kein Software-Update machen.
Alter, gehen wir nicht auf den Sack.
Ich habe 64G.
Ja, reicht.
Guck mal.
Ich habe 64G Speicher auf dem XR.
Und davon habe ich 42 available.
Du brauchst nichts.
28 wären doch ganz nett.
Dann ist man auch immer noch bei unter 40 Euro.
Ja.
Dann ist man auch immer noch bei unter 40 Euro im Monat.
iPhone zum Tauschen haben wir leider nicht.
Ach cool.
Ach ja, für das alte iPhone kriege ich glaube ich 30 Euro oder so.
25 Euro und 5 Cent.
Zum Glück können wir einen Kredit aufnehmen, der den tatsächlichen Preis zusätzlich verschleiert und in Verdaulich...
Die Frage ist bei solchen geilen Krediten ist immer, wo man genau gucken muss,
ist es nach diesen 24 Monaten wirklich vorbei?
Weil es gibt ja auch Kredite, da bezahlst du keinen Zinsen in dem Sinn,
sondern du hast dann am Ende noch 200 Euro Rest, die du noch zusätzlich bezahlen musst.
Was halt auch fragwürdig ist.
Wenn du dann schon zwei Jahre bezahlt hast, dann am Ende nochmal irgendwie 200 Euro drauflegen musst.
... Häppchen einteilt.
Was ist hier passiert?
Natürlich ist unser Beispiel überspitzt.
Aber so oder so ähnlich funktioniert Upselling tatsächlich.
Man kreiert mentale Stufen im Kaufprozess und schafft so viele kleine Vergleichsmomente.
Die Vergleiche erscheinen alle für sich genommen rational.
Klar will ich lieber eine etwas bessere Kamera.
Natürlich will ich das neueste Modell und auch nicht zu klein...
Wisst ihr allein schon, warum ich das iPhone SE nehmen würde, wenn ich mir eins kaufen müsste?
Wie gesagt, ich musste mir das XR glücklicherweise nicht kaufen.
Weil ich ganz ehrlich der Meinung bin, dass...
Ich habe jetzt den direkten Vergleich zwischen dem iPhone 6 und dem iPhone XR.
Ich finde das XR von der Größe viel angenehmer als den fetten XR-Klumpen in der Hosentasche.
Wenn ich speicher...
Beim XR rutscht einem ja schon fast die Hose, wenn du kein Gürtel drin hast.
Die einzelnen Vergleichsoptionen erzeugen immer wieder Druck.
So gelangen wir ganz langsam von Punkt A, einem Handy für 466,90 Euro, zu Punkt E, einem Handy für 925,05 Euro.
Und jeder Schritt für sich hat sich irgendwie logisch angefühlt.
Nur 100 Euro mehr oder ein paar Euro...
Tomli, das ist natürlich schlecht. Sollte eigentlich nicht passieren.
... im Monat im Kredit.
Wäre die Situation aber folgende gewesen.
Entweder das XR für 467 Euro oder das iPhone 12 für 925.
Wir hätten uns wahrscheinlich eher für die moderatere Variante entschieden.
Erst die vielen kleinen Abwägungen und unser hoffnungsloser Versuch...
Moment, Moment. Spicke, Spicke, was ist ein Fanny Pack?
Was für ein Ding?
Was ist denn ein Fanny Pack?
Fanny Pack...
Ach, so eine Bauchtasche. Okay.
Ist das modern wieder?
Früher hat man sich darüber lustig gemacht. Jetzt ist das wieder modern?
Okay, naja. Ändert sich ja immer mal wieder.
Eine kluge Entscheidung zu treffen, haben uns hierhin gebracht.
Das Ganze wird natürlich noch von Apples klugem Webdesign unterstützt.
Nichts ist zu aufdringlich. Der Prozess wirkt vor allem benutzerfreundlich.
So oder so, für Apple ist Upselling eine Goldgrube.
Schauen wir uns dafür insbesondere mal den Speicher an.
Beim iPhone 12 kann man viel machen.
Beim iPhone 12 kann man für 165 Euro und 75 Cent...
Ach, über die Schulter trägt man das jetzt.
Aha.
...zusätzliche 192 GB Speicher erstehen.
Dieser Speicher ist ein NAND-Flashchip.
Wie viel Apple pro Wohn-NAND-Gigabyte bezahlt ist, schwer zu sagen.
Nicht viel. Guckt euch mal SSD-Preise an.
Der Marktpreis lag im August bei circa 6 Cent.
In unserem Fall verkauft Apple jeden NAND-Gigabyte für circa 86 Cent.
Ja.
Also Preise für Speicher ist der Witz.
Kein Wunder, dass da keine Micro-SD-Slots drin sind.
Das hatte Apple, glaube ich, noch nie, ne?
Verkaufspreis noch einige Kostenpunkte.
Aber der Mehraufwand für Apple, einfach den jeweiligen Flashchip auszutauschen, ist sehr gering.
Das macht solche Speichererweiterungen äußerst profitabel für das Unternehmen.
Ein Bloomberg-Artikel von 2018 befasst sich genau damit.
Stonks Artikel.
Hier wird die Gewinnspanne von einem Market Analyst bei anderen iPhone-Modellen auf knapp 70 Prozent geschätzt.
Er nennt den Speicher schon damals absolut das profitabelste iPhone-Feature.
Als Kunde mögen die 166 Euro in dem Moment vielleicht fast logisch wirken.
Sind ja ganz schön viele Gigabyte.
Aber für Apple werden es basierend auf den Bloomberg-Zahlen 116 Euro Gewinn.
NAND-Preise sind in letzter Zeit außerdem ordentlich gefallen.
Also ist es vielleicht sogar noch viel mehr.
All das sind natürlich nur grobe Schätzungen und Spekulationen.
Wie viel Apple am Ende hat?
Wie viel Apple am Ende genau woran verdient, ist schwer abzuschätzen.
Der Speicher von iPhones ist jedenfalls nicht mit einer günstigen Micro-SD-Karte erweiterbar.
Warum nur?
Anders als bei ähnlichen Top-End-Smartphones.
Das kann technische Gründe haben.
Wer weiß.
Ach so, wir haben unser iPhone ja noch gar nicht zu Ende gekauft.
Zu guter Letzt können wir noch eine Versicherung abschließen.
Für nur 169 Euro.
Das nennt man Cross-Selling.
Hier will man kein Upgrade, sondern ein zusätzliches Produkt.
Oder einen Service verkaufen.
Ein bekanntes Beispiel wäre...
Hätten Sie gerne Pommes zu dem Burger?
Und naja, wenn ich eh schon 900...
Leute.
Das Schlimmste ist Subway, was das angeht.
Das Beispiel wäre...
Wer war in letzter Zeit mal bei Subway?
Bei mir ist schon eine Weile her.
Aber Subway ist das Schlimmste, was das in der Richtung angeht.
Wenn du da was bestellst und keine Ahnung hast,
da kommt dann extra Belag, extra Käse, extra Sesam-Zeug drauf.
Extra hier, willst du da noch irgendwie extra sowas haben?
Da kommst du von einem 5-Euro-Sub,
kommst du irgendwie auf einen, keine Ahnung, 15-Euro-Sub.
Und hast nicht wirklich mehr bekommen.
Also Subway ist der Meister des Extra-Kaufense.
Aber es lohnt sich doch nicht mal.
Subway lohnt sich eh nicht.
Das einzige, was man bei Subway essen kann, ist Sub des Tages.
Eventuell gepaart mit Menü, weil es früher, glaube ich, nur 2 Euro oder 2,50 Euro mehr gekostet hat.
Dafür gab's dann All-You-Can-Drink und Cookie, das ist okay.
Dann hast du dann 7,50 Euro oder so bezahlt für ein Menü, vollkommen in Ordnung.
Mittlerweile ist es wahrscheinlich viel, viel teurer.
Was auch noch geht, ist, wenn du die Subway-Gutscheine hast.
Das ist auch okay.
Aber normal zum Subway gehen.
Ein normales Subway-Sandwich mit dem normalen Preis.
Und das ist der Witz.
Da bezahlst du 40 Euro für ein Sandwich.
Hätten Sie gerne Pommes zu dem Burger?
Und naja, wenn ich eh schon 925 Euro ausgebe, will ich vielleicht auch,
dass ich im Falle eines Unglückes bestmöglich abgesichert bin.
Apples Website ist ein Paradebeispiel für Upselling online.
Viele mentale Stufen im Kaufprozess, die wiederum viele kleine Vergleichsmomente erzeugen.
Der Kunde soll sich in diesen Vergleichen verlieren,
die in kleinen Schritten immer wieder Aussicht auf etwas Besseres bieten.
Apple ist aber natürlich bei weitem nicht das einzige Unternehmen,
das Upselling oder Cross-Selling betreibt.
Man nehme zum Beispiel die Produktvorschläge auf Amazon
oder aber auch die recht neuen Bestell-Terminals bei McDonalds.
Da sieht man, dass ich schon lange nicht mal bei McDonalds war,
weil habe ich noch nie gesehen.
...haben wir vor einiger Zeit schon mal in einem Video gesprochen.
Sie sind sehr gut darin, dir durch verschiedene visuelle Techniken
mehr Burger oder ein größeres Menü anzudrehen.
Vielleicht hilft es manchmal, etwas mehr über Preise zu denken.
Und wie einem die Dinge präsentiert werden.
Es sind vielleicht nur 100 Euro extra, wenn man eh schon 800 ausgibt.
Aber für was bezahlt man da? Lohnt sich das wirklich?
Bezahl's für die Apple-Aktie, dass sie weiter steigt.
...einer klugen Kaufentscheidung.
Cheers.
C.U.
Hey, hoffentlich hat euch dieses Video gefallen.
Ja, du sorgst dafür, dass der Apple-Aktien-Stonks
Kurs raufgeht.
Nicht mal liked. Ich kann gar nicht liken, ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
Am besten ist eh erstmal gucken, was der ganze Kram bei AliExpress kostet.
Gut, bei einem iPhone geht das jetzt nicht.
Aber bei vielen anderen Sachen geht das.
Gerade wenn man Technikkram braucht, der letztendlich eh aus China kommt.
Und ob man sich jetzt China aus Deutschland importiertes China kauft
oder direkt in China, ist fast noch besser.
Ja.
Natürlich bei Sachen, die exklusiv sind, wie bei Apple oder auch irgendeinem Nvidia-Grafiker, dann geht das nicht.
Aber Elektronikkram? Immer China-Gucke.
Zumal's ja auch gar keinen Unterschied macht, ob ihr das in China bestellt und die das dann zu euch fahren
oder ob das jemand anderes bestellt, hierher fahrt und ihr kauft's dann da.
Würdest du dir auch 1000 Euro Grafikkarten über AliExpress holen?
Nee.
Da wirst wahrscheinlich gescamt.
Wo ist der Unterschied von AliExpress zu Wish?
Wish ist das AliExpress für Kack-Noobs.
Wish ist im Prinzip AliExpress, nur dass noch Wish dazwischen ist.
Weil Wish verkauft den Kram ja gar nicht selbst.
Wish stellt eine Plattform bereit, wo Leute Sachen verkaufen können, die sie gar nicht haben
und dann einfach eure Daten an den China-Hersteller weitergebt, den ihr auch direkt kaufen könntet,
bei dem ihr auch direkt kaufen könntet, sagen wir mal bei AliExpress oder Banggood
und die schicken's dann direkt aus China zu euch.
Oder von irgendeinem EU-Warenlager zu euch.
Also im Prinzip ist Wish bestellen, AliExpress bestellen nur für Kack-Noobs und mit Scam-Garantie.
Zoll musst du dir keine Gedanken machen.
Also aus China sind die ziemlich gut drin, die Zollsachen korrekt zu deklarieren.
Oder zumindest sie so zu deklarieren, dass sie nicht beim Zoll landen.
Und wenn du ganz auf Nummer sicher gehen willst,
dann gehst du zum Beispiel, wenn du hier bei Banggood irgendwas bestellst,
dann bestellst du mit EU-Priority-Line.
Und wenn du mit EU-Priority-Line bestellst, dann hast du eh kein Problem mehr,
weil diese neuen Zollbestimmungen, die ab nächstem Jahr gelten,
die gelten nur für Sendungen, die direkt aus China oder aus dem Nicht-EU-Ausland an dich geschickt werden.
So.
Und was die mit EU-Priority-Line machen, ist ganz einfach.
Das ist eigentlich Big Brain Strongs Logik.
Also Massive Brain, was die Chinesen da machen.
Das bedeutet, wenn du EU-Priority-Line bestellst,
dann entweder schicken die das direkt aus der EU los,
weil die ein Warenlager in der EU haben.
Oder zum Beispiel Niederlande mit PostNL und sowas in AliExpress.
Oder aber zum Beispiel schicken sie es erst nach Spanien.
Und in Spanien wird es dann quasi an dich geschickt.
Das heißt, für dich ist es eine Sendung aus der EU in die EU und du musst keinen Zoll bezahlen.
Ja.
Zollbeamte hassen diesen Trick.
Genau.
Ey, aber das ist auch so.
Euch kann da eh nichts passieren.
Wenn schon ist der Hersteller dran, wenn er Scheiße baut.
Aber das kann euch ja auch egal sein.
Und ja, ich hatte auch viel mehr Probleme aus den USA,
weil es die Hersteller aus den USA nicht hinbekommen,
die Sachen richtig zu verteilen.
Und auch nicht mehr zu deklarieren.
Ja, ich kenn das gern.
Beste.
Huge.
Ich mag die Musik halt auch.
Das bieten die an, genau.
Und nachdem jetzt neue Zollregelungen ab Anfang 2021 in Kraft sind,
werden immer mehr China-Hersteller gar nicht mehr das Normale anbieten,
sondern gleich direkt EU-Priority-Line, EU-Prior...
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was der Unterschied dazwischen ist.
Das Zeug für den Fernseher war halt ultra teuer,
weil ich aus den USA bestellt hab und die es wieder nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt haben.
Ja, da wo ich fast das Doppelte bezahlt hab,
nach Zoll und FAT und Mehrwertsteuer und Zollgebühren
und hast du nicht gesehen, Versand,
als das, was es ursprünglich in USD gekostet hat.
Ja.
Echt so.
Keckweh.
Max, was hast du eigentlich für dein Ducky-Keyboard bezahlt?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Das hab ich jetzt schon zwei Jahre oder so.
Was kostet so was?
Ich denk mal, dass ich sowas in dem Dreh bezahlt hab.
Wahrscheinlich so 100, 115 Euro oder so.
Oh, das ist ja günstig.
Das ist ja ein Schnapper.
Warum ist das so günstig?
Warum kostet das nur eine Million?
Erhalten Sie 6 Euro Rabatt.
Das macht jetzt die Sache auch nicht mehr fett.
Ah.
Moment, ist das überhaupt Euro oder waren das irgendwelche Rubel oder...
Das ist eine China-Seite.
Das ist einfach mal eine China-Seite.
Teko bei Suite 2611 in Langham Place, Agile Street, Mong Kok, Kowloon, Hong Kong.
Alles klar.
Klingt äußerst vertrauenswürdig.
Was übrigens auch gut ist, dass es reduziert ist.
Also ich bin ja froh, dass es von einem Euro-Dollar-Dollar-Dollar-Dollar
in der Karte ist,
aber ich bin auch froh, dass es von einem Euro-Dollar-Dollar-Dollar
in der Karte ist.
Also ich bin ja froh, dass es von 1,2 Millionen auf nur ungefähr knapp
eine Million reduziert ist.
In den Warenkorb. Easy.
Ah, Express.
Stimmt nicht bei SSL.
Null.
Ist das ein Fake-Shop?
Was kosten da andere Sachen?
Ne, okay, andere Sachen heißen halbwegs normal.
Heiße Artikel.
Ja, Kowloon war eine DLC mehr als Black Ops 1.
Ein wahrer Schnapper.
Soll ich mal ein Screenshot machen?
Lului.
Okay, sehr schön.
Ich muss grad mal kurz was gucken.
Hat Windows irgendwie...
irgendwie Whois oder sowas?
Haben die sowas?
Ja.
Guck mal die Linux-Kiste an.
Kurz gucken, auf wen das registriert ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich...
Ach ne, für DE-Einträge gibt's ja gar nichts mehr, ne?
DE-Einträge...
DE-Einträge sind ja...
Kannste ja nicht mal Whoissen.
Ost.
Ja, mal kurz mal in der Linux machen.
Ach, jetzt ist es doch...
Moment.
Es ist HTTPS, aber not secure.
Warum nicht?
Moment, warum...
Warum ist es not secure?
Ach so, weil eingebundener Content nicht SSL ist.
Ah ja, okay, okay.
Also, Moment hier.
Also, zeigt man ja.
Ah, Cloudflare 2.
Naja.
Ja, gibt's nicht mehr.
Ah, Cloudflare auch noch.
Alles klar.
Exzellent, exzellent.
Mix-Content, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Die Musik ist nice.
So, Leute.
Wisst ihr was?
Ich muss schon die ganze Zeit mal aufs Klo.
Und ich krieg Hunger.
Wir machen jetzt Schluss mit Aufwachen und Streamen.
Ich hoffe, ihr sind alle wach.
Vielleicht spielen wir nachher noch eine Runde Battlefield 3.
Aber zumindest spätestens morgen, wenn Venice Unleashed rauskommt.
Und es zu sinnvollen EU-Zeiten rauskommt.
Dann spielen wir Battlefield 3.
Und kurz gucken, ob es da irgendwas Neues gibt.
Interessiert nicht so wirklich viel Leute, ne?
Primers.com
Discord.
Exzellent.
Ach so.
Ich hab's hier noch nicht im Browser aufgehabt.
Verstehe.
Also, Leute.
Alles klar.
Schön, dass so viele wieder dabei waren.
Entweder sehen wir uns heute Mittag noch mal mit ein paar Runden Battlefield 3.
Oder morgen, falls Venice Unleashed zu ordentlichen EU-Zeiten rauskommt.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Modding-Pack für Battlefield 3.
Die aber angeblich auch Custom-Server direkt zu Release haben.
Mit neuem Content.
Mal gucken.
Heute Mittag, ja.
Ja, Vettel, wenn du wieder mit Battlefield 3 spielen willst, sag Bescheid, ja?
Also, wir sehen uns, Leute.
Bis dann.
CU.